like an hour extra get queuing Arab to
talk about stuff 1-0 the Stars have
aligned the prophecy has come true Alex
Jones and Eddie Bravo together on
episode 9 1 1 this is episode 9 11 no
I'm not I had to [ __ ] work hard all
week to grind out podcast to make sure
that I hit episode nine eleven when we
booked it I knew how I go okay there's a
certain number of podcasts I have to do
to get this to nine eleven so Jamie and
I worked it out and we did it let me
just say I'm very envious because I'm in
my studio under bright lights and I've
talked about going back to when I was
just on radio that darkness we can
really think this is a wonderful studio
I'm gonna do a studio my next one with a
fire pit I'm gonna have conversations
outside I've talked about that yeah
cause it's like primitive it triggers
yeah and now it's comforting it feels
good and it's kind of cool lighting so
that's in the next studio we build I'm
gonna build a fire pit I'm gonna get
some logs some actual real fire you can
only do that like certain times of the
year in LA though like when they when
they have fire season they wouldn't let
you do that [ __ ] we will use have like a
little balcony or like a little outside
courtyard with your fire pit you kind of
don't want a real fire pit you know like
I feel like if you're gonna have a fire
pit wearing black shirt yeah you should
have actual long Hawaii part of the year
and I will too and then we'll just a
roaring fire in the jungle and create a
whole Renaissance just what we're
talking Donald for the show that could
fix a lot we could fix a lot with that
Alex Jones you're like a decorated
correspondent for the news now what the
[ __ ] going on what do you mean I mean
you're a hero you were out like a fishel
White House guy now right oh no the King
like you're actually like a news guy
like 100% legit Bureau and stuff but
that's just part of it yeah but like
you're you're in deep with the Trump
administration well I've had Trump on
and I talked to him some but I mean
really he's your buddy
really really it's just that we're
covering the resurgence of America what
made the country great lower taxes
empowering the people bring people
together
the opposite of what MSM said what's
happening is mainstream media is
literally almost dead it's collapsing I
mean look at you I mean I'm never having
dinner with you like six seven years ago
you're like yeah we got a million
downloads a week now it's 90 million or
whatever it is a month and 20 million on
YouTube and for Infowars it's similar
numbers it's a good weeks 40 million
we've had as many as 85 million people
listen on radio and tune into videos in
one week that was election week but our
normals 47 million it's just crazy how
can they compete with that they're still
delusional
the average CNN show is like a million
viewers fox thinks it's the big swing
and dick it's got three four million
it's all I'm sorry people transmitting
and broadcasting to geriatric homes you
know where you see Fox News to CNN and
nursing homes you know what you see with
kids ten years old ten years old up to
college and beyond - Joe Rogan
experience and it's Infowars and it's
all these other folks it's amazing yeah
it's a weird time isn't it it seems like
those shows where you have to tune in
from 8:00 to 9:00 and you have to sit
through the commercials that's kind of
all gone away because of DVRs because
now people just have to wait a few
minutes you could DVR through all the
commercials or you record things after
the fact I don't remember you like 15
years ago saying the internet killed
television they haven't announced you
watch it's gonna kill it because how can
they compete with what you can do on the
internet you know a guy getting screwed
by a horse or whatever it is they got
jacked by the tiger today let me not pay
admission and just go through here well
they even shot at the tiger
so they scattered the Tigers they shot
at the Tigers to get him off this dude
and then even after the bullets were
shot off this tiger was like nah [ __ ]
that I'm going back in and he ran in
after they shot at him and finally
killed the dude and it was all
everybody's got their phone up and
they're all filming it jumped in he
jumped in he wanted to get killed oh
really yes yeah he wouldn't know this
that was another guy who went in with
the line and tried to convert them to
Christianity sure see there that guy
that's crazy he went in with a Bible
he's trying to convert the Lions the
lion just [ __ ] him up I'll tell you
what's crazy about that though is
imagine oh well I'm trying to convert
him maybe he was just like
praying that the [ __ ] line
wouldn't he know he went in on his own
he was talking to them in the name of
Jesus and he's like talking to though
you never seen it
Jamie pull it up
see here he is he gets in there and he's
talking to the lines this [ __ ]
just jumped the fence and decided he was
going to convert the lines of
Christianity and lions are apparently
like way cooler than Tiger like what is
going on here Tigers see people and they
just [ __ ] him up immediately the lion
like barely [ __ ] that guy up he just
kind of that's because they're they're
more tribal or more like dogs pack
animal there's only cat that's in a pack
or a group so they're not you know as
aggro exactly mean a tiger sees you
you're in my territory I'm going to kill
you yeah yeah Tigers a totally different
beast like Tigers sometimes I'll like
adopt a notable animal like a wild dog
or something like be licking on the big
nice to it like what other ones eat it
yeah they do weird stuff remember the
only way you could see this before is
with those animal attack videos remember
those animals we started the same way
there was they start off with the dog
attack a dog attacking a mailman and
iguanas out attacked your leg and then
it slowly ends up with drunk Mexicans at
a rodeo on a wild bull with a rope and
those bulls are smart as hell and they
drag these drunk Mexicans and they drag
their heads along the rails and just
brush these dudes in between the railing
like some serious brain trauma yeah
vicious brain trauma they need one word
it with just a hundred percent of that
cuz that was the most exciting [ __ ] now
Jones how the [ __ ] is TV gonna compete
with that
see that's what we're saying okay that
was kind of wrong though cuz Netflix is
TV and it's also the internet it's like
both things sure and it's forcing the
power of Hollywood to basically disperse
though yeah well they I mean look it's
it's better if it gets if if the ability
to get your workout gets to more people
it's better it's better if anybody can
do like these much more competition it
yeah these new YouTube stars like all
they have to do is get stand in front of
a camera
this is zero production value they don't
have that I mean
if you got a camera you got an internet
connection you could have a youtube show
people find you interesting all of a
sudden you've got millions and millions
of subscribers I mean Andy was bringing
up this fact for your audience up front
a lot of MSM lies and says I'm this big
right-wing guy but you guys know that I
was really against george w bush you
were you were arrested early on in the
bush administration i remember when when
we first became friends in 1999 we were
running around the white house are the
the state capitol lawns with wood with
George Bush junior and senior masks on
and you were always again sure the Bush
supported Trump is the entire power
structure the media I mean the Vatican
of the Communist Chinese the Saudi
Arabians all put money in and said stop
him stop him and then lines that the
Russians were giving you money with no
proof and so the issue is he's simply
trying to actually be President and not
have special interest in their running
him and that's why the whole power
structure is against Trump
so and he was asked before going live
well how was here this outside guy
against the establishment but now you're
for it no Trump's trying to create a
beachhead you just to explain it to try
to take the country back and actually
devolve power back to the states and
back to the people doesn't mean he's
perfect but notice the stock market went
up a trillion two hundred million
dollars you know just the last month or
so because a lot of institutional
investors and others understand with
Trump he's trying to create real
prosperity not a bunch of social
engineering and I'm not here to pitch
Trump to people the issue is is that
there were major intelligence agencies
and and Patriots in the government who
were sick of what was happening and
we're sick of Hillary and Obama backing
jihadist groups and other things and so
they're rolling those groups up right
now they really are standing up against
them and this is a historic moment and
so there's been a counter-coup through
the electoral process in our country and
that's what WikiLeaks was that wasn't
the Russians that was u.s. intelligence
agencies I said two months ago that
Anthony Weiner in New York you know may
have a Dean's husband the former
congressman that was working for Hillary
I said that he's under investigation for
child porn okay and then now it came out
yesterday that they're looking at and
IDing him for child porn well I had that
from the NYPD that came out yesterday
yes Wow why would it what did he do he
had something on his computer
well now that they won't tell us but I
was told that tied into that whole pizza
gate thing which again the media
misrepresented what we
and it came out and all those WikiLeaks
all these weird coats okay like there
was a bunch of weird codes about pizza
and about a piece of Pete President
Obama wants $65,000 in hot dogs
delivered and they're like are these
really good hot dogs hot dogs weren't as
good last time well these are succulent
hot dogs okay that's not about kids you
have to be well what isn't that about
it's male prostitutes I mean that's what
the code means really yeah okay yes how
do they get male prostitutes to keep the
[ __ ] mouth shut
well cuz you know bad things happen if
you dumb federal child porn charges
possible for Anthony Weiner but but I'm
on record months ago I'm on record
months ago saying that that's the case
because I had those sources and so the
government good elements the government
know what's really going on so the media
that misrepresented and said oh look at
4chan they're talking about a thing
called pizza gate and some pizza place
in DC and the media looks at it says oh
alex jones is claiming all this bad
stuff is happening in this pizza place
I'm like what is this
so they divert some probably innocent
pizza place to distract off of all the
emails that the New York Police have and
the FBI have that's just this monstrous
reported pedophile Network
so to discredit that they go create a
fake story hoping we jump on it - then
divert over to that story
and then once we're on that it diverts
everybody off from Anthony Weiner what
which this reportedly which leaves
reportedly hold a larger network so
they're playing that far ahead so
they're they're literally attacking a
pizza place with fake stories just so
that people can focus on that and take
attention off of Anthony Weiner yes
because I was connected to that story it
was connected to Podesta stuff in
disaster in New York and all this other
crazy stuff so because we're making a
lot of like long sentences here in a lot
of long statements but let's let's throw
a lot of people that are go what the
[ __ ] is pizza gate there was this Ben
Swann guy who did this recent piece
about it and a lot of people got very
angry did you see the piece yeah I see
the piece that he did it seemed to me to
be pretty measured and he was making
some connections to between that little
that's that symbol for child pedophilia
yes and we're just pedophilia right and
the logo the logo for the pizza place he
also may
did he make the Hastert connection with
Podesta well we passed your confirmed
child molester and and and best buddies
with Podesta and former Speaker of the
House and then you expand on that but
let's put Stu Stuart step at a time okay
this is really kind of important stuff
so that's all 100% true right so it's
true that Hastert's in jail it's true
that Hastert is a known pedophile that a
judge called a serial pedophile right
yeah that's true is a hundred percent
it's true that Podesta was friends with
Hastert that's a hundred percent right
yes and then all this other stuff now
becomes odd doesn't it become odd and
but if you say it's odd if you look at
it this Ben Swan guy with this what I
thought was he was just kind of
expressing what is weird about this case
and when he did it he got so much [ __ ]
over it I was kind of shocked I was kind
of shocked people calling him a [ __ ]
and that's the same thing but but that's
what I'm saying they built a straw man
imagine thousands of emails come out
with them talking about we'll have the
kids ready six seven and eight in the
hot tub at this time and there didn't
see anything like that oh it gets really
weird it's a that it was emails there's
a freaking thousands of them but it said
we'll get the kids in the hot tub yes
I never saw that can you see if you
could find that Jimmy that seems like
the whole thing is so bizarre like we're
gonna have the kids delivered for
entertainment they'll be in the hot tub
now these are great kids but kids can be
kids well you know what's [ __ ] up
about it is how few people really
mention that connection to Hastert I
would thought that would be a huge huge
consolation I love the fact that you're
very astute I just bring up this whole
big topic of how they twist things you
go right to the key points that okay
he's a be a Barney Frank who got caught
running a underage male prostitute ring
in the 90s out of his three-story
townhouse yeah I thought it was just a
male prostitute thing I didn't know and
I was with him all up to age 19 plus or
whatever sure but but then what happened
is he goes on c-span
on the House floor and says if you
continue to investigate this I'm gonna
expose half of you that are involved in
this in this room an investigation got
shut down so the reason this is
important
as for shadow government you need
something so bad that everybody who's
involved in it ever ever comes that will
be destroyed so that binds them all of
the secrecy so that's where child
pornography comes in and that's where
pedophilia comes in that's where you get
so many of the elite being into it but
just as you shed you have the Republican
establishment trying to get Hastert out
of nowhere as a wrestling coach to run
for office then reportedly he's the pure
cure just like Penn State and just like
they had send us key Sandusky in the
underage you know kids they were quote
mentoring getting farmed out to
supposedly big donors what's crazy this
is where was who we're talking about two
very specific cases or at two very
different cases but what's crazy as
they're both real it's both real 100%
Sandusky who was a very respected man
the community did a lot of charity work
with young disenfranchised children and
was molesting them at the same time and
was super respected in the community and
he was the right-hand man to Joe Paterno
so that whole thing just developer and
the headquarters from our research of
the pedophilia is like Pennsylvania
right okay that's a franklin cover-up
that's that's up in what does this see
Jamie says we plan to heat the pool so
possibly Bonnie will be uber service to
transport Ruby Emerson and Maeve Lozado
11 9 and almost 7 so you'll have some
further entertainment and they will be
in that pool for sure what in the [ __ ]
that's only one of them and that's a
real confirmed email right yes Jesus
Christ so listen here's the problem so I
have NYPD telling me before the election
like a month before yes we're
investigating Weiner child porn photos
go back not just a not just of kids out
on the internet but but kids he's
communicating with and their parents are
basically letting them communicate with
him so I'm told this by NYPD detectives
I mean the Secret Service gave me
information about Hillary was collapsing
all the time remember we reported that
then it got caught on tape so so so all
this stuff goes on and on and on and so
I'm not saying half the people or 90% of
them you know are guilty or innocent in
all this all
I know is we start covering it start
asking questions
they then divert off into somebody on a
fortune forum pointing out there was
some email about a meeting at some pizza
place in DC where top Democrats go they
then turn the whole thing into I'm
blaming some pizza place
I'm sending shooters and to shoot people
it a pizza place make up all this
crazy-ass crap when I never even said
any of that and then you go back to me
two months ago three months ago I said
the police have told me they're
investigating Weiner for pedophilia and
child porn when it was not the news now
notice it gets in the news release slow
now before we get away from this because
I gotta go back to that there was a
quote up there that Jamie pull up that I
wanted to read the one on the lower
bottom about this now this these are the
emails that you were talking about and
these are 100% confirmed emails go back
to that one that was on the bottom they
scroll down and I know these people are
guilty yeah what is that hold on a
second here so six grown-ups with two
toddlers and two infant spread
throughout the house and sure enough one
of the toddlers was rubbing my nose at
5:45 what the [ __ ] does that mean
the FBI has got back to retrieve the
children they threw in the towel and
what I don't know man this is like I
don't know what the [ __ ] those emails
mean but look let's just now I mean
everybody wants to immediately shoe.this
aways disgusting love it impossible
right we're talking about two very
specific proven cases yes
Hastert proven Sandusky proven real huge
elite powerful people that were also
active pedophiles right yes so that's a
fact
who know each other in her buddies and
then you've got Podesta's brother who's
big in Washington in an article in 2007
in the Washington Post I'm gonna try to
give the exact headline which was
something like radical art or something
and it's like naked photos of the
neighborhood kids in their house and
then they're showing it throwing at your
face
it's just crazy but that's not even
stuff I get into but they would but
there is something to that because some
of his artwork was super disturbing that
he had in his house like Louis about
this pink butts
they were in their underwear and it
looked like they had been paddled yeah
and they were all stand there with their
butts faces hairy but more about this
than I do see and that's all I do is
cover these real take so let me give the
notice what that is real the government
got pissed off about this the pedophile
rings have gotten so big that the
intelligence agencies began to leak all
this info and they knew Hillary was
planning to steal the election she did
steal five states according to the
experts in proof we how did she do that
what I mean let's listen trying to break
into six days let's not go on these
wrong line rants where there's a bunch
of different statements that need to be
addressed sure so let's just from right
there you got to get to that like how
did she steal five states can't kind of
gloss over that okay no she tried to how
did she try to steal six states she did
steal five states well Beth Harris was a
big liberal big Democrat at the HP of
documentary hacking democracy right he's
the leading expert she was actually my
month before the election through
whistleblowers got the actual code that
had been loaded on machines all across
the country should have her in studio to
steal the elections I saw hacking
democracy and I saw that they did
engineer those voting machines so that
you could have a third party input and
change it and did it on live on the show
and and that was a decade ago with Bush
this is new okay so when she's the top
election fraud expert so she comes on my
show the stories on infowars.com and she
says we've got evidence and then I had
the hacking experts on and I had the
industry whistleblowers on and I had the
county officials on it every level we
have the fraud proven that Democrat
connected grips were already loading
code on the machines all over the
country but it's different companies but
about thing was eighteen percent of
machines in the country to be able to
remotely break in and flip votes so
because they were aware of that a bunch
of states were waiting and watching and
homeland security broke in live into six
states and kept trying to flip the
results and they even have screenshots
and videos of them in the computers in
their clicking and doing it all there's
major investigations going on you hear
the news wink trucks crazy he claims
illegals voted to make anybody legals
that was one statement in a larger
election fraud deal of actual computers
so so Trump knows about all this so she
comes on and says they're planning this
front then she comes on after the
election she says yes it's clear here's
where precincts closed here's where all
this happened we're a hundred percent
went for Hillary or right after it
closed all the votes that then came in
were hundred percent for Hillary
they didn't even care but the landslide
was so big for Trump they couldn't steal
it she successfully stole five states
she tried to break into six others or
her controllers did and got blocked the
the tsunami for Trump was so huge with
the real polling we can break down later
that they still weren't able to steal it
and now Patriots inside US intelligence
agencies are preparing to roll up the
pedophile networks nationwide that's why
you've seen arrests in Pennsylvania
arrests in la I haven't seen these
arrests who's kidding it's just now
breaking and it's it's big
institutionalize 174 arrests 28 sexually
exploited children rescued during
statewide human traffic operation
they're getting all nine we should take
over right holy [ __ ] but look at the
numbers they're 474 people arrested but
they're only rolling up the Renfield's
that get the people for the psychic
vampires there's no one sane is it that
this is still happening right so all the
people that thought that this idea that
you know what I mean whether they tried
to make it ridiculous by calling a pizza
gate or connecting it to a pizza place
everybody that thought that was
ridiculous it is not ridiculous that
there could potentially be some sort of
a pedophile ring and see how they
traditionally how they trick us they go
pick some pizza place probably have
their people go on make comments on some
message board CNN New York Times
Washington Post the same day come out
and say well all the emails are
discredited from New York in California
and Hawaii because there's this innocent
pizza place over here that some of the
Democrats go to and they're all saying
that's where the pedophiles are at okay
so then the internet all goes and looks
at that and starts trying to prove to
disprove MSM that oh there must be
something going on there
so then that turns that all into the big
quagmire is a smokescreen from all the
admitted stuff that's happening because
again I was told by my NYPD high-level
sources that that they've got all this
stuff on weiners computer that just got
scooped up you know during the whole
hacking story and the whole story about
Hillary and the unsecured servers and
that that was being blocked by Obama and
that as soon as Trump got in they would
go back after Weiner then I was told
about former section chief from a CIA
that indeed this was an operation they
were running against him to start
leaking all this and
what you're beginning to see is the
beginning of all the pedophilia coming
out as they roll up the procures that
grab your kids out of backyards or the
devil out as social workers and get the
kids or whatever they're rolling all
those up right now to get to Renfield's
Renfield brings the people to Dracula
okay that's the allegory I'm not singing
right I know you said so they're gonna
now roll it up into the higher level
groups right now here's so here's what's
going on with a lot of this stuff yeah
you have to be real careful and how you
describe these things and how you talk
about these things because people are
looking for any little tiny thing to
discredit it and one of the reasons why
they're looking at they're doing it for
personal reasons because it seems you
you no one wants to be ridiculous no one
wants to be a fool and no one wants to
be someone who's talking about
conspiracies that aren't real so people
are very hesitant to to talk about
something that's unproven but horrific
is just like 15 years ago it was a
conspiracy theory that that the Catholic
Church had any pedophilia right now we
know 35 30 percent we're doing it we now
know the old Pope had to step down was
blackmailed with info about other
high-level priests by the new guy that
came in I mean this is heavy stuff the
Catholic Church stuff is absolutely
horrible and proven over and over again
and again when I was a kid it was rumor
it was just things were whispered and
you would hear about it and now it's a I
always wondered how they're getting away
with it it's so out in the open how come
there is it more psychic vampires
stealing the energy from the kids
well what the most common thing they do
in jail
the most common thing they do is they
find very troubled kids that don't talk
about it people with foster care kids
with no parents kids who come from
really troubled backgrounds but you
would Sandusky Ranny abused children's
shelter and group and then would take
the kids out sometimes overnight at rich
people's houses to make him feel better
yeah yeah it's and the number was to
believe that these that the assistant
coach and that all these powerful people
but when he finally got caught he was
raping eight-year-olds in the showers at
noon on a Saturday at the field house
yeah and someone who worked there found
it watched it happen it walked in on
them literally and that's what would it
all fell apart that's those guys get
more and more arrogant it's all I'm
telling you
I'm not saying anybody's guilty in these
thousands of emails you go read him and
it's like the last walnut sauce she
brought wasn't very good oh well these
are good walnuts you're gonna oh I love
walnuts and then you go reading the FBI
breakdown what that's code for
what's code for walnut means people
brown skin oh Jesus Christ
fool well you know understand I was
talking about this for years
FBI chief formerly he discovered a bunch
of it in Los Angeles he he was the head
of the LA sector so people are gonna
hear this they go they're a bunch of
pizza gate truthers these guys are a
bunch of pizza gate truthers there's
there's an inclination to automatically
dismiss things let me be clear let me be
clear
I I'm on the year covering 50 topics a
day these emails are coming out I I get
contacted one of my sources by people in
the NYPD I get sent documents photos of
their license law enforcement I talk to
these people then they say ya know it's
horrible it's a bunch of pedophilia you
know it's it's a bunch of child porn
it's all gonna come out it's tied to all
these different groups and I'm just like
okay so I go on air and I say listen I
got this from real NYPD and other
sources and then Eric Prince of
Blackwater who still runs all the
biggest groups in the world as he runs
some sort of military operation and but
like Bahrain or some you have some what
the point is is that he comes and says
the UAE can ask you about it he knows
all about it but the point is is that
all this happens and he comes out in the
news okay through the White House organ
Breitbart that's basically from Trump's
mouth and says yes we've confirmed
high-level pedophilia rings in the
Clinton operation we're gonna bring them
down and so that's what all this is why
did Breitbart tweet about that in 2011
do you remember that tweet right Martin
Obama came out right Bart said I'm gonna
bring out the biggest thing that's gonna
bring down the Democrats and they
poisoned him right here in California
you need to be poisoned you know
absolutely they killed him where did
what happened I didn't even know how he
died I thought he died of a heart attack
oh yeah are you laughing fake laughing I
won't buddy you know I love you anyway
go up the Breitbart email or the
Breitbart tweet cuz it's a crazy Joe
knows all about this well the tweet is
insane when you read it you're like wait
what the [ __ ] is going on like everybody
it's there's an instantaneous reaction
that people have right you tell me
people are doing this to kids you don't
write you like get the [ __ ] out here
that's nonsense yeah but when you tell
people about the stuff that's been
proven the ones that happen they don't
account they don't call don't attach
those I was on air sang I'm told this by
NYPD in like three different shows and
there's gonna come out that Weiner
sending child porn and it's in the news
though what they're saying what they're
accusing Weiner of apparently is sending
sexually explicit text to an underage
girl
that's what's against the law it's so
they're calling the child porn but it's
essentially he was sending pornographic
text to a fifteen year yeah well I was
told it's a lot more than that what the
renew is there's just what it's doing is
minimizing it because the higher-ups are
being told you don't let this out mmm
let me tell you wieners supposedly had
tens of thousands of emails Weiner
should be a [ __ ] comedian for sure
he's a freak he's got real problems is a
good communicator I bet he's hilarious
come on don't you think all I know is
I'm not saying even Weiner is a
pedophile all I know is all I know is
listen we all know about Jerry Epstein
okay and I don't know about your little
Oleta Express just Google that and what
is that Bill Clinton's like on 20
flights first of a cell oh that's right
and then he was also flying to this this
Middle Eastern country with his sheikh
that's admitted pedophile with
multi-million dollar checks at Bill
Clinton on the plane and Bill Clinton is
a known sexual predator okay so all this
stuff's going on and so they start
bringing up lawsuits against Donald
Trump with jane doe's claiming he'd been
with Epstein even though there's no
proof in the law because I'd make you
log even on private jets none of it was
ever true he'd been in here is how
Prague Prague you know progressive guru
John Podesta is in household name is
world class underage sex slave up cover
up ur defending unspeakable dregs
escapes me early on did John Podesta
imagine his baby
mmm FA I don't know what that is would
be covering up for underage sex ops and
H you know hate crimes against Blacks
huh I know what that means what is MMF a
young Jamie Media Matters
hmm isn't that Soros yeah that's Soros
but also guess who owns the pizza place
who wear all this one on its it's
Media Matters head guy David Brock's
boyfriend and that is where they have
major Democratic Party fundraisers and
then they had they had rock bands there
that that gave live spoken word
dissertations of the love of children
what yeah I'm talking about guys like in
goth track talk about how much they love
children have you seen this yeah I don't
even really want to repeat but they
really pull it up one there's a video of
them saying that it was Justin Thomas
this is a common ping-pong so you know
what Y is I mean this it's really it's a
very very bizarre subject but why is
this like so eat what is this right here
you bring it up Jamie give me some
volume
[Music]
[Music]
hmm that's super weird first of all the
comic ping-pong right anybody listening
let's describe what that person looked
like they were wearing a wig a blonde
wig and it was a guy a transvestite or a
woman who's just smoked every cigarette
it's one of the two but this is the fact
that that was going on at that place
seems really odd but that sounds like
someone ad libbing you know we all have
preferences like trying to be funny
that's almost like no guys in the in the
in the oh yeah a lot of creepy artwork
can they talk to that guy
a lot of creepy artwork I mean that
that's a fact there's a lot of facts so
it's one of those things like anything
you're not saying I'm not either that's
what's really important I never even
really covered this stuff and then they
had me on the news and also Swan going
they said these people were killing kids
in a basement they say okay megyn kelly
went on and took a clip where I was
talking about Hillary's funding jihadis
and Obama back in the Arab Spring that
killed tens of thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people
thousands of children now al Qaeda was
putting kids and which is Isis into sex
slavery they edited that out and then
cut it together on Fox News with me
saying and Hillary Clinton rapes and
kills children in a basement at ping
pong Pizza
they literally now edit audio but I was
able to changed your audio
I was able to go find the day with video
with what I really said and throw it
back in their face wow wow that's really
blatant that's what where's this can we
watch this where where is this that they
did sure I think you guys have to come
to the comparison to the two up yeah
it's something like megan kelly caught a
giant lie against Alex show trying to
find that we should we should play that
megyn kelly so pretty she'd say whatever
the [ __ ] she wants she was like old
training I love her
do you think she looks like an old
[ __ ] yeah you're hilarious no I don't
like old trainings but I think she's hot
you know like you don't think Megan
Kelly's not just want to insult she's a
globalist Oh obviously she's pretty do
you know Joe she's real ugly she do you
think that she was she's moved over to
n-b-c do you think she's gonna change
her tune now and go for the lady she
wants to be the quote new fox news so
they'll be the new kind of Glenn Beck
I'm a conservative but I hate
conservatives and libertarians and I'm
speaking for everyone and I can decode
it all so she's gonna go over there to
be the conservative light and try to get
them some ratings so it seems like NBC
realizes that's where the money is is
that we're saying wanna see how fake
news is made from megyn kelly on Fox
News do you find it Jamie okay let's
play it here here we go give us some
volume it's a gate conspiracy gunman
many controversies do these days it
began with a tweet on October 30th days
after the FBI announced they'd be
reopening an investigation into Hillary
Clinton's emails someone on Twitter
whose name remains unverified but has
several thousand followers posted that
new emails found on anthony Weiner's
computer confirmed that hillary clinton
was involved in a pedophilia ring the
Twitter post included information from a
Facebook user who stated quote my NYPD
source said it's much more vile and
serious than classified material on
weiners device we're talking an
international child enslavement and sex
ruin a pause for the next day the places
nobody back up two seconds now this is
probably the cult trying to debunk us
what they do is they misrepresent what
we're saying
so again whoever these rogue people were
or I don't know they are saying oh look
NYPD says it's Weiner and all this see
how they were saying none of that's
happening now it's actually starting to
come out I don't know how far how deep
it goes but this is when Kelly let's let
it play out and then respond to it out
okay book user who stated quote my NYPD
source said it's much more vile and
serious than classified material on
weiners device we're talking an
international child enslavement and sex
ring the next day the bogus claim was
picked up by a website called your news
wired.com message boards like 4chan and
reddit right wing blogs and several
protes Infowars alex jones a far-right
web host posted a youtube video seen
almost 500 thousand times
[Music]
children Hillary Clinton is personally
murdered
and abs Jiro fear standing up against
the rumor spread inspiring some newfound
Internet sleuths to start digging around
in John Podesta's hacked emails
searching for proof and location of the
so-called sex ring what they found were
numerous references to pizza now here's
what Alex Jones actually said children
Hillary Clinton is personally murdered
and chopped up and great AB zero fear
standing up against yeah you heard me
right Hillary Clinton has personally
murdered children go tell that long
tongued liar
go on I just can't hold back the trades
anymore Hillary Clinton is one of the
most vicious serial killers the planets
ever since
there's a twist of that am i talking
about the devil worship story with her
chief of staff or campaign chairman
looking at the menu of blood and semen
and body parts that's Aleister Crowley
event a private event oh no I'm not
talking about that
I mean 200,000 plus dead Christians with
her operation with Syria and our
operation in Libya and not let the
Christians get out and directing al
Qaeda and Isis who target and murder
children and put up their sex slavery
and throw Catholic priests off cliffs
and kill people in mass and murder gays
and everything else you can imagine
because they don't like peaceful people
and they cotton by this therefore open
society and they love everybody anything
they do is for degradation and someone
could have been killed inside of your
restaurant are you no good reason I'm
sorry people like Alex Jones and a
conspiracy theory that even the DC
police say has no basis in fact yes it's
a pack of lies and it's dangerous what
happened to sorrow somber boyfriend to
drive across four state lines with an
assault rifle and enter a
family-friendly restaurant at 3 o'clock
in the afternoon on a Sunday I know
reddit has banned this topic on its
website
I mean slowly but surely those who help
fan it are trying to dial it back out of
the safety you know the concerns for the
safety of those who have been endangered
by really this could happen to anyone
it's not just us it's any single person
I know you said to our producers it's
all so surreal until the gun comes in
Wow so they got the full clip they cut
the front off knowing I was actually
saying I don't know about the Satanism
before the term pizza gate was out there
but I do know she's funded the radicals
I came I saw they died who do rape and
kill and cut up kids so she personally
is you were making a very provocative
statement and you made a very
provocative statement by saying
something kind of crazy at first yes and
then backing it up
and so what they decided to do was just
edit a chunk of that and so they didn't
really have to edit it and chop it up
but they did take it as a czar
take it out of context and said that I
was talking about comedy right you
weren't and I was talking about the
spirit cooking Aleister Crowley stuff
where the lady is written it's real for
her and they go they take little kids of
these parties and they have vats of
blood that's one thing if you were an
adult wanted to do that you know issue
some art project this is real and so I
wasn't about the menu where there in the
email saying you know we're gonna have
plenty of blood plenty of semen for you
and other delicious things on the menu
and he's like what are the juices on the
menu a mango well we're gonna have
cheese pizza we're gonna have we're
gonna have the nut sauce and we're gonna
have the pasta and we're gonna have you
know succulent hot dogs we know you love
succulent hot dogs when they go oh god I
want to go back to that place in a why
that had the best hot dogs you know it's
like yes since we've got hot dogs you
know Obama wants $65,000 or the hot dogs
liver the party well the hot dogs be
there and then it's in Stratford the CIA
emails that got leaked by WikiLeaks that
now people cross-reference where the CIA
is like watching ah ah ah look at Obama
in Chicago another hot dog party well
the there's a nice Obama is at a party
with 15 dudes that's his issue the point
is though they can blackmail him with
this and the stuff with Obama that's we
never got pedophile codes with Obama
yeah no it's it's men I mean he's had
this are you trying to say that Barack
Obama is a homosexual saying he's
bisexual how dare you I really don't
even care yeah have you ever seen him
with a man how do you know this is true
well I've seen him with men walking down
the street maybe he just likes to bring
dudes didn't have conversations with him
maybe he just works very hard to talk to
people when you in the head of the free
world maybe he had a party with with
$65,000 for the hot dogs yeah maybe he
loves hot dogs he's sick [ __ ] it [ __ ]
this diet I'm not the president anymore
yeah I'm chilling now listen 5,000 hot
$65,000 he's balling that's more than
5,000 hot dogs what a gourmet hot knows
what a dollar piece to Christian how
many let's say it's super gourmet $5 a
piece for each other president needs a
hot dog helping hands what if it turns
out he was like the ten-time hot dog
eating champion he's like one of those
let's say you actually just really likes
hot dogs here alex jones right but
listen you know you gotta get those
delivers someone's gonna make them gotta
grind it
put it in the casing the whole deal
maybe he gets like gourmet hot putting
together some giant party some I'm out
of this job party no I don't know but
these are code for male prostitutes okay
maybe this what I'm saying is
anybody who's skeptical anybody who's
looking at this and going do you guys
are so [ __ ] crazy this is so you're
making such gigantic leaps of faith no
leaves just look at all how with the
weird code in those emails there was
definitely some code Joe after this one
in fact my crew actually got mounted be
honest with you was slaughtered by the
truth sir we're about five days into
this and the news hadn't even picked it
up and all my crew is doing is all day
reading thousands of emails I mean
there's thousands that are just related
to food and hotdogs and kids and hot
tubs and kid deliveries and oh and oh
the spirit cooking at O Aleister Crowley
and oh they'll be semen in blood I told
my crew I said it's probably true no
one's gonna believe it stop obsessing on
it and stop reading these emails because
I want to focus on the election and
everything else that's happening so then
sites start accusing me of covering up
the the Podesta stuff before it's called
pizza gate and then I get blamed for
being behind pizza gate and I'm not even
bitching I'm explaining what it's like
to really be trying to get at the truth
and then people take the fact that it's
complex she'd be better at this than me
do you know how to put stuff out clear
and parse it I just know all this crap
well you get crazy and still ran people
won't listen to me because I got too
much data and you made what this is like
I mean it's just I'm sick of it I don't
know everything that's going on but I
know this I have good CIA people and FBI
and Secret Service okay telling me yes
Alex it's worse than you know keep
hitting them it's gonna come out and
it's starting to come out and saying
watch when we start arresting the
pedophile networks we're gonna roll up
the Democrats and the Republicans that
are involved that's why Trump said in
these speeches at the inaugural this is
not about parties we're taking these
people on we're bringing God back in
even smart that wasn't very religious
like Trump has gotten religion learning
about this because let me tell you
something Trump's not a devil worshiper
and he loves God and he's been briefed
on all this and he's gonna roll their
ass up
so the pedophiles better get ready I
want you clear something up right now
look at that camera and tell everybody
you're not bill Hicks
tell no stupid to tell him you're not
I'm not either tell him well nobody's
[ __ ] people think there's a goddamn
conspiracy here's what happens they
think it's a flat earth - I take real
stuff notice Joe Sena's research not
kissing his ass so he knows all these
little points I'm making better than I
even did yeah I'm like remembering
Stefan he brings it up because I try to
suppress after this crap I can't handle
it anymore man I'm 43 and I'm sitting
here looking at all this and then and
these people comfy on the street they go
Hey Joe Hey Joe 75 times and that I
tried like oh I knew you were you know I
mean not just jealous though Alyx
whatever your [ __ ] name is I'll be on
the street or I'll be at a restaurant
and they come over they go they say hey
Bill hey Bill hey Bill I'm really show
Rogan that's versity oh I know it's you
all because I did a few pieces in one
little video with a guy that lived in
Austin that you know it's how I met you
but you don't like Bill Hicks that's
what's ridiculous about it like what did
you get like massive plastic surgery
changed the way your voice sounds like
your voice is so different than anything
is that no one ever wants to look real
conspiracies because they're complex and
hard to understand they want to just go
with the earth is flat
you know there's aliens living
underneath the Capitol dinosaurs aren't
real or well no I mean listen the point
is I'm gonna bash it's good to have a
free open mind but he doesn't promulgate
stuff
he's only researching what's been said
so I want to just get this out of the
way I am Bill Hicks I'm actually you are
how old Bill Hicks be like 60 I think he
died at 32 in 1994 so do the math I know
one thing it's hot in here is it really
oh no no I always pee much do you get
really cold oh do you well you get crazy
you're a goddamn Elgin Inferno I'm
melting you know there's a lot of people
that don't know like how you got started
but one of the things I thought was
really bizarre in that thing was that
lady was calling you a right-wing host a
far right-wing host you've never been a
right-wing guy and it's a it's a big
misconception like you were always
totally anti Bush you got arrested
speaking actually before Bush was even a
letter
you were trying to stop him from being
elected back when Clinton was and when
he stole the election from Gore who I
didn't even really like I still came out
and exposed it and it's now been
certified in Congress and there they've
documented I just go with what the facts
are but you've never been one of the
things that really opened my eyes this
is a really important video that you did
9/11 road to tyranny we talked about the
World Trade Organization protests and
how they had sent in these people in
government uniforms with
government-issue boots and these
anarchists that were dressed in black
and they it's that this is an actual
tactic that they'll use to break up
peaceful protest well they'll send in
soldiers or policemen or whoever the
hell they're hiring no one knows and
they send these people and they smash
everything up they start it turn into a
violent protest and light things on fire
and then they all holed up in a building
and they negotiate their release and
none of them were ever arrested oh and
when you showed this clip by clip from
these various news organizations and you
focused on the kind of clothing they're
wearing and the difference in their
behavior versus the behavior of all the
peaceful protests and then showed the
result of it which had these people that
were walking to work with a WTO sticker
that had a line through it and police
stopped them and said you can't have
that sticker on that book bag you can
admitted beta test for martial law again
I'm not anti cops themselves the media
always spins it you expose pedophilia
they blame some innocent pizza place you
expose the government trying to make
cops do bad things now you hate
everybody not even been cops mean who
knows who was Delta Force that makes
sense
Delta Force my my blasting Delta Force
they were given the order by Clinton to
go out and it recruit and they recruited
just about 400 leftist foundation-funded
Gribbs funded by big private foundations
they trained him for about a month
before in Oregon they flew him there put
him in a government housing facility
this was on the news later I just
covered local news story they did
retreat to a building and negotiated
their surrender and they were released
yeah yes yes this is after all this
property damage they went out to start
the attack so they had it on video so
they could then attack the hundred
thousand peaceful protesters so this was
something that I mean we don't like we
like to think just like you don't like
to think that
pedophiles are real you don't like to
think that anyone in the government
would ever organize some kind of an
attack or some sort of a fake event
we're a bunch of people that you hire to
start smashing things to make a peaceful
protest look bad we don't want to think
that that's possible but it is boss it
goes on but it turns out that this is
actually a documented yes tactic yes it
was the WTO in fact Esquire about two
years ago was doing a profile on me and
you know the guy his dad had been a
former CIA section chief and had been
involved a bunch of stuff himself and I
told him I said yeah Delta Force ran
those riots and he goes you're a liar
and I said no I'm not he he went and
googled it and couldn't believe he got
the Seattle post-intelligencer jury and
stuff and then even went and talked to
journalists that knew because he'd been
there covering it as a journalist and he
didn't even know so he says in the
Esquire article okay Alex Jones got me
there because even though I've grown up
the CIA and stuff I don't know that was
happening but but let's be clear it's
criminal elements using
compartmentalization that do this they
always claim I hate the government and I
won't have a war and all this other
stuff no I have to give credit to the
good elements of the CIA and the good
elements of the NSA I mean I'm good
friends that's a very important point
it's a very important point I've had
this point with a friend of mine when we
were talking about I've had Mike Baker
on the podcast before and through the
few conversations that I've had with
Mike Baker who's formerly the CIA I get
you start getting an understanding of
how it works like these drug dealings
that always you don't want to like jets
crashing with all the coke on board
they're Cowboys you got like a few dudes
guys running sad sad shows a few dudes
who realize they can make a fuckload of
money if they sell and there might be a
lot of people involved but it's not the
whole CIA it's not like they have
government memos on it what I do is they
all have a cover and option they're
running the president says do this like
Ronald Reagan didn't know about the
cocaine dealing I talked to folks that
were involved actually for the points he
says I want communists knocked out
Congress doesn't give them the funding
they go what you do in the government is
you go the president said do this we're
men of action we're going to do it so
then there's cocaine already being sold
the Contras are using it to get all
their funding we'll screw that we'll
just jack it bring it in using private
contractors right and there wasn't the
first time they did it there wasn't your
face
but yeah it was it was a common tactic
they knew that there was money that was
being made from selling illegal drugs
why would they let that money be made
all around them they're not going to
that's the argument is you don't want to
let the Communists do all the cocaine
and heroin dealing or the curse then
they have more money than you well what
the [ __ ] is going on in Afghanistan it's
just this crazy people how much heroin
production went up since our occupation
anybody can pull this up that's what's
frustrating is a lot of the fake
liberals cuz I see myself as a real
liberal but a lot of the fake liberals
just go oh that's a lie this is like no
you can search engine opium production
in Afghanistan pre 2001 and then look at
the latest years it's come out like
2014-15 it went from 3% of world supply
to 7% the 30% and after ten years of
occupation it went to 93 percent look at
the global supply so look at the hectare
just went from was i right well there
were it's pretty substantial increase
between 2001 which is at an all-time low
on this chart from 94 the 2016 so 2001
is an all-time low and then the next
year it [ __ ] skyrockets yeah but
Google BBC and ap just type in
Afghanistan 90 plus percent world opium
production that's a very very 93 percent
listen and this is also for like opiate
pills or is it just for everything every
so it's not like oxycontin's and things
they ordered the troops to the Taliban
that works whether it was allowed to
grow it and then they're allowed to sell
it to whoever wants to buy it well not
just that there's been documented
confirm instances of troops that are
being forced to guard poppy field sure
well let me break it down for right when
they sort of come backs on Fox News with
Geraldo Rivera absolutely that sharable
that came out of here after I broke it
and again let me tell how they work it
comes out that the troops are being only
right there it goes 90 percent of the
world's supply of opium according to the
United Nations and hit 93 last year this
is how many years old is this a couple
of those like three years old yeah it's
two years old say it's gone from 93
right now Jesus Christ show but she had
in line I said 93 and it's not what it
is yeah so but that's what's so
frustrating as you know all this and
then and then people still call you
crazy
know what Alex
I do explain the fake new SIOP why do a
lot of people out there think Infowars
is total fake news why do they think
that that is a major deep state
government program funded by Soros
mainly and they found the most effective
way is anti-israel bashing and so this
came on the WikiLeaks last year the US
intelligence leaked not the Russians
that he's in there saying we're gonna
overthrow Israel we got a deal with
Saudi Arabia and we've got a like up the
ante with anti-israel rhetoric I'm
somebody that was neutral in Israel
never been there have nothing to do with
that Israel has liberals conservatives
some good administration some bad but
I'm not anti-israel it's a tiny little
place I know it does some things that
are bad compared to what we've done it's
nothing so I just don't have some giant
hard-on for Israel you know willing to
hurt them and I'm not against the
policies or anybody else everybody knows
that so so when they kill Israelis for
no reason I say it's wrong when they
white phosphorus bomb Palestinians that
say it's wrong so I'm sitting there
covering all that and then they just put
out that I'm this Israeli agent you know
all day long or I'm the CIA let's not
get into these crazy rants about crazy
accusations why do they think Infowars
Wars is faking is I don't know you that
a lot of people out there smart people
really intelligent they they think the
real news is CNN okay well unexplained
you've got attacks from below and above
you've got major funding by Soros and
others who's a real live Nazi
collaborator like true dr. evil the
latest James Bond was based on his real
company it's even named after his
company you know he's a bad guy in the
movie is actually Soros yeah he tried to
crash the pound bring down Engel and
he's really bad news so mi6 hates him
but long story short about George Soros
he's funding this attack on me and any
independent media how do you attack
independent media when the public's
awake to deep state and government stuff
you say Alex Jones is the government and
then they always ignore real facts I
talk about where I admit some of my
family and stuff this worked for the
government and they said the government
was corrupted out of control that isn't
even a real debate but but above that
what was your other question he had a
question with his question was explain
the salt Eddie let me let me just
explain it's pretty easy they're in
direct competition with him if it's Fox
News if it's CNN if it's anybody that's
distributing news you're into
a competition with someone who has an
independent news organization they
operated themselves and they do it
online
Jose you said it perfectly that's it
alex is in a very unusual position
because he's a magnet people people are
drawn to him like a lightning rod he
says a lot of crazy [ __ ] he goes on
rants he's very animated he's fun to
watch and a lot of this [ __ ] he says
it's correct and we're getting into this
right now
like this this thing about the WTO which
was like I said was one of the first
ones that really opened a mine that was
a long time ago - that was like you put
that video out in AU 2002 or something
like when was that 2003 I was like 2001
yeah right after 9/11 yeah right after
September 11th and I really put it on
the web right I said exactly I put it
out on like DVD or something before that
but you just hit it joke so let me try
to actually think and codify this then
because my problem is I don't script
what I say that it's kind of all over
the map which is a good thing also a bad
thing you just put it on the head you
ask your question why they call me fake
news we just saw megyn kelly two weeks
before the election say in a whole
hour-long show special against fake news
we spent a few minutes of it Alex Jones
is the king of fake news he just said
Hillary is chopping up children inside a
basement at a pizza place now granted I
was saying it in satire about her in the
Middle East yeah so it begged for them
to take it out of context but they
clearly did that to deceive their
viewers she's branding herself I'm real
you can trust me look at this poor
victim Alex Jones almost got him killed
when none of it was true when none of it
was your based in reality and when I
what I was getting was from the NYPD
okay and the FBI who are who are good
people at least those agents so there's
an example of them branding text CNN
they'll take something real I've said or
they've taken videos where I'm acting
stupid you know with like 5x or 6x
underwear they're giving the illegals or
whatever and they'll show me with
underwear on my head and say look this
guy's crazy and I get it I cover serious
topics so they can take it out of
context but when I'm being serious which
is 90% of the time I tell people but
when Joe comes in and we've got we have
no Joey so he did so Joey Diaz talking
about you know kidnapping people I start
laughing or well yeah we had fun look
you're a normal person and that's that's
what people find hard to believe when I
tell people I'm friends with Alex Jones
they go get the [ __ ] out of here he's a
great guy
it's a great guy we have a good time
together look you're very nice chill
you're a great guy ice wish we weren't
all so busy didn't hang out more like
the old days I know well we can do it
I'm gonna come back to Austin I'm trying
to get to Austin probably this spring
trying to figure out when and when and
where I'm gonna get but I love Austin
where you live is a [ __ ] beautiful
place well I know these topics can be
you know quite frankly exhausting we are
first they are but but I'd like to shove
today really get into the big picture
and what I believe is really going on
because I figured out the basis of
what's happening and I'm gonna let you I
mean if you wanna hear some far-out
stuff today okay because we've
experienced I mean I'll go through it
okay let's go okay let me take a piss
then god it was always so slick and calm
so are you reading me not getting here
we're gonna bring you down we're gonna
like bring you down to earth every now
and then you're gonna launch into orbit
we're gonna grab you by your heels bring
you back we're gonna be fine we'll get
through this go take a piss and then
tell us some title [ __ ]
right through that door and to write
powerful works Jones so far any Bravo
everything you wanted and more oh
absolutely I'm just sitting here letting
and just letting letting the people let
your fans know that have never listened
to my listener Alex Jones every goddamn
day and should take a day off every now
look [ __ ] he's a good guy you know he's
always been a good guy
people that don't listen to him they
they believe what the mainstream media
has said yes but it's also he makes it
easy for them by saying crazy [ __ ] like
Hillary Clinton chops up babies and all
that stuff and I know he's doing it for
dramatic effect it's one of the reasons
why his show is so popular because he
does a lot of things like that it makes
it easy for people to dismiss him and
then you get into this thing well okay
let's before you just miss him let's
look at what he said what does he said
it's true and then look at what he said
everything he said today so far robbery
before everything that he said it's just
like his radio show yeah he doesn't have
any teleprompters this dude can talk for
four straight for that that's a thing
though when you wind up doing a lot of
podcast especially doing these radio
shows shows like Alex says by himself
we're just rants and rants and rants for
long periods of time you'd they develop
like a certain muscle like there's a lot
of guys who do their own pot like bill
birnes perfect
example does his own podcast by himself
all the time and he's got this ability
to go just rant from one subject to the
next subject and keep going and when you
have him on a podcast it's just you just
kind of got to get out of his way yeah
so with Alex he just kind of got a feed
him some subject get out of his way but
every now and then he does so many
subjects in a row I got to bring them
back I gotta go you got us okay let's
get to this one how did she steal the
states you just can't cross over that
let's get to this okay let's get this
broke it down pretty yeah you did a
great job yeah and this is uh I think
this is gonna help people have just
seeing Alex like this is gonna help
people have a chance to look at this
whole picture of just forget about where
your loyalties lie whether you enjoy CNN
or Fox News or whatever they just sit
outside of it right now
and look at what it really is because
what it really is is why is anyone want
to give you the news are they giving you
the news because they love you or are
they giving you the news because it's a
program and they're trying to make money
and do they have access to certain
people because they're willing to play
certain games most likely when you're
looking at something that's on a major
league television show whether it's Fox
News or NBC or CBS or whatever the [ __ ]
it is you've got to go through some
serious channels to get there this
happen if you're a guy with a suit and a
tie good evening America and you're
doing that guy that that guy on any of
those major networks you've had to go
through some [ __ ] serious hoops and
ladders and checks and balances you got
to represent something in order to be
the person who reads the news but what
is that news for is it a [ __ ] show or
is it really the news are they really
trying to help you what are they trying
to do you know what why why are they
doing the news are they doing it because
they love you and care for you and they
want you to be informed or they doing it
because they're clearly biased and
they've got an agenda well if you watch
Fox News and then CNN just go back and
forth whenever is something going on
like I would I did it after the election
I was like Fox News CNN Fox News CNN
it's who the [ __ ] is telling the truth
someone's got to be lying
why don't you [ __ ] is lying one of you
[ __ ] his line because this is one story
over here there's a totally different
story over here so all you need to know
just looking at that just forget about
what you are whether you're progressive
liberal whether you're a conservative
Republican just look at that and
understand
and that you're getting all of your
information from these sources that have
a vested interest in relying particular
version of the truth that's not good for
anybody it represents the like Fox's
totally no matter what Freddy bravo to
let's get crazy bring out the hatchet
I hope that people that listen to your
show bring out the whiskey all I want
like for me I don't want to be this
conspiracy guy making money and and
doing shows I walked away from my
podcast I was talking about conspiracies
I really don't want to be that
conspiracy guy but something inside me
is wants to wake people up that's all
I'm trying to do that's all I'm trying
to I'm trying to help I'm not making
money off any conspiracy theories or
anything I told myself every time I walk
in here don't say [ __ ] about
conspiracies whiskey's gonna bring it
out of them bro he wants to roll with
you later oh no every now and then don't
you want to be like on that side and
just have have full access they don't
let me give you guys the big freakin
[ __ ] I got the thing figured out
pour one for Eddie I got to figure it
out guys oh [ __ ] poor little me
alright gentlemen Cheers
here's to you Alex Jones here's a you
buddy BUTT STUFF
people were so on one side or the other
when it comes to this there's so much
anticipation regarding this so much
bullying about they don't have Alex
Jones honorable well there was a lot of
that there's a lot of you gonna call him
on his racist [ __ ] someone said that to
me but you're my Alex Jones is one of
the least racist people you'll ever
[ __ ] meet in your life
I've never even heard you say a racial
thing race is so inconsequential to you
I mean what you think and what they
stand for
you've never discussed race ever in the
almost
do I know you 16 [ __ ] 17 years I've
never heard you discuss race at all so
someone calling you a racist like what
you just all they do while trumps waving
a rainbow flag and say he's a homophobe
there was a guy walking next to me in
New York I was there after the election
I was there for the UFC he was right
after the election and me and my friend
campaigns were walking back from the gym
we went over to the gym we're walking
back we walked right into the [ __ ]
protest and there was this guy that was
standing next to me screaming Donald
Trump KKK racist sexist anti-gay KKK
racist sexist anti-gay he just kept
screaming it out as if Donald Trump's in
the KKK as if Donald Trump are you sure
he's racist are you sure there's any
discrimination she hires gay guys who
run his casinos and hotels and his
friends with him and like gave
interviews of The Advocate
20 years ago it's all just complete
made-up horse crap he's blazing a
rainbow flag at the RNC speech he says
Republicans have to stop being mean to
gay people and have to be inclusive he's
about to enforce civil rights laws for
gays and others and they're calling him
a literal homophobe now listen privately
upside-down BS man yeah but this is my
problem with it my problem with it is
that people want to use a real you're a
bigot you're this you're that they want
to come up with a nice quick label that
officially makes them on the charts you
in to make sure that it boxes usually
defines you and then you have to defend
yourself look you said it best at the
beginning this Donald Trump is not
perfect he's a man and he's also a super
ambitious super wealthy man that's
constantly on the go and those kind of
dudes are type-a hyper aggressive
personalities and he's definitely said
some shitty [ __ ] enough said right
I mean don't you agree like we all do
yeah and that this the big one is one
that he said in confidence with that
Billy Bush guy the grabbing by the [ __ ]
thing that's the big one who has it in
confidence especially if you're famous
[ __ ] man it's crazy women throw
themselves on you you can do anything
you want sexual assault a woman's
climbing up on top of you you can do
whatever you want that's what mammals do
she's showing she wants it she gets it
I'm a sexual assault it's pure horse
protection of a woman steady I just I
could just see it in their eyes I could
just go up and grab them in the balls
we were on the map we would allow for
[ __ ]
Rhianna just talked about her she'd [ __ ]
any guy she wants just walks up to him
grabs him by the dick we would be like
crazy totally we would think it's
amazing the side of my group is he
wasn't talking about that he hides
behind bushes and works for joggers
reaches out and out of context he's
having a guy conversation but like he
described it as locker room color this
is whole but this isn't shine with the
recorder yes and this is not defending
it I mean it's definitely not something
you should have said probably right we'd
all agree to that but what is he really
doing he's really what we call talk and
[ __ ] like Eddie talk [ __ ] so much to
each of laughing saying things we
totally don't believe we totally don't
mean but we're trying to make each other
of the beach oh yeah we're worse le
Eddie and I are silly all the time you
had a transcript of all the
conversations you and I have had over
the [ __ ] 17 years we've been friends
oh [ __ ] we'd be in trouble can't put it
on air we'd be in [ __ ] real trauma
content on Facebook mentions into that
live video you guys are being so funny
watching the stupid TV show oh my god
that show was awesome and then as soon
as I turned the camera on you would the
cell that Stefan wasn't minimal was bad
but it was like off-the-cuff you weren't
you know you weren't censoring by don't
forgot what I said to a lot of marijuana
involved in this conversation you don't
like them you don't have to worry it's
so loud you don't have to worry about it
ah Alex Jones is here seriously I just
want to do a good job and actually reach
out to your so one hundred and hundred
and ten million who knows how many let's
know you got nice alive downloads a
month twenty million on YouTube all the
derivatives and everything else you're
doing and I agree sometimes on XM you
still doing that no no I'm not on the
XML whatever the point is is that you're
one of the biggest shows in the world
let me give you little news flash not
for you no okay we need to know this I
don't know
as a signal to the mainstream media
without pathetic they are CNN's top show
has maybe a million viewers their
average show about a hundred thousand
Fox's top show maybe four million a
night on a bigger night okay great good
for them
I'm not competition with them the point
is they're a freaking joke i
conservatively every day on terrestrial
radio have four million listeners on my
200 plus stations that's rated proven I
mean that's big right there and then
millions and millions of downloads every
day tens of millions people watching the
videos you've added all together 40
something million a week
we go back to this what's happening it
isn't about Joe Rogan or Alex Jones or
Eddie Bravo or any of that it's about
the people are hungry for being able to
have a wider selection of things totally
different categories because all I'm
trying to do is give them interesting
content you're actually trying to run a
new show and expose a really smart
commentary i watch flips on I have
people on all the time it's just you try
to open minds all the time I try to open
minds a different way what I'm not
honestly not trying to open minds I'm
being curious and I'm asking questions
and I'm trying to learn as much myself
and then once I do learn about things I
would like to have that person come on
to teach other people throughout because
I think it's interesting
well here's the big enchilada for folks
if you want a belay the sound shelana
actually break this down but there is a
whole breakaway civilization and UFOs
get ready I don't ever talk about this
for real breakaway civilization are you
ready
hold on Joe how many things did I tell
you over the years too many too many
that's true there was a couple that you
got wrong all right 2k people thank you
all the context let's learn that explain
the white okay a conspiracy theory is
just not trust in criminals every now
and then you can't pin that murder to
the criminal but he's still a criminal
even though you're wrong well one of the
things I'm actually embarrassed about is
the watch okay well hey listen you're
not a conspirator not a computer expert
in here am i I didn't go anywhere that
night I stayed [ __ ] home and I was
waiting for that goddamn power to go out
12 I didn't know I thought damn the
Mayans knew we thought it was over 2012
December 2012 license I did oh yes very
strong tobacco from Mexico I am in
California this is 100% medical reasons
and legal
yeah man there's still look there's a
lot of things that people think are
gonna happen that turn out to not happen
there's always a goddamn asteroid it's
gonna kill us all that doesn't actually
so what what is going on aliens are
coming well let me into Peru let me
before I do this let me answer his
questions he had a tragen question -
yeah
let me answer y2k because I want to be
about honest about this okay this is one
of the few things that that I have
really gotten wrong and I didn't go with
my gut and so I was proven wrong and I
did it for the wrong reason so now I'm
gonna actually confess your honor
I was on one radio station I've been on
access TV for a few years I was on one
radio station already started to show
out of my house that was on like 15
radio stations so I had that at least
but I was on one big radio station at
the top show at night station with
Howard Stern killer was all over the
newspaper had huge ratings and I was
bringing in like you know 20 30 grand a
month which was just a huge amount for
me building a whole operation out of
that at home and they come to the cells
guys and they go look for a year you've
not been behind y2k and you're not
letting us have all these big sponsors
and you're gonna basically be fired if
you don't let us endorse these sponsors
and have them on air and say you believe
in y2k hold on a second so these
sponsors were like doomsday stuff like
canned food and [ __ ] and bunkers
everything else so the station made you
push y2k what let me go further this is
one of the few times in my life that I I
don't wanna say I didn't have integrity
I kind of let them convince me but I
think back to the point in the
conference room I just kind of went okay
okay okay sure I get it and then I went
and then once I decided it was true I
really pushed it so it's almost like I'd
lied to myself yeah because I'm being
honest about this process so so this is
what happened for a year and a half I'm
saying it's be as if the government hoax
because they're like the Navy says the
chips are all bad in 54 cities will
completely fall and it's all the death
and I said they just want to upgrade
with all this new spy hubs they want a
new global standardization for the u.s.
it's the Telecommunications Act of
nineteen six they want to force all the
new chips because I had NSA sources then
that I was having on okay and I didn't
realize how special it was that I had
these sources they're telling me it's
all bs people don't argue with the navy
and don't run and fox news that adds
that your food it was just everywhere
someone oh ok hell ok stuffs gonna be
real so it was like a Black Friday for
dudes the Black Friday those for the
last few months and the moral was they
didn't fire me anyways
they did but the moral was I kind of
to myself it was real so by the end of
it of course they edited like you know
12 hours to be on that day and like five
minutes I'm totally insane right but
it's like nuclear reactor having a
problem here and it really was happening
and like you know oh and there was a
missile fired from Russia which light
was an ICBM and they got like shot down
that was ABC News so I'm like alright
this isn't really happening ok you know
we got prepared it's all gonna be
prepared but hopefully our reactors
having a problem ok some stuff so there
was some outages and some problems but
government and MSM had hyped it then
they used it to demonize alternative
media even then when it wasn't
catastrophic so my gut told me it was BS
it was BS and so thank God I missed the
whole 2012 thing but still they said
Alex Jones says the world's ending the
bureau 2012 where he research what I say
it was the listeners they were pissed at
me I wouldn't go into this thing well
it's fun for them see when you start
talking about the end of the world their
doomsday come and people like that [ __ ]
because it gives them something to think
about it was a long time ago 17 years
ago right y2k yeah 17 [ __ ] years ago
at least ten thousand twelve didn't get
you something redeemed yourself yeah
think about 17 years ago that's a long
time ago I mean in you getting fired
from that job every great radio guy's
gotten fired Howard Stern got fired you
got fired like public loves but it was
just like our Stern fire I've had top
ratings and they were all pissed and
weird about it the weird thing is they
didn't mess with the losers they were
all flipping out cuz I was getting the
big paychecks well it makes sense it was
the same and the y2k thing totally makes
sense that they would want you to really
push that and sell it hard because who
the [ __ ] knows you know we don't know
you get scared you like what I'd miss
relics the Navy says it's gonna happen
Washington Post now your listeners are
it was the one time I went okay maybe
I'll go do it I had people on they were
telling me there was something that was
gonna happen on 2012 they were sure of
it
do you start like stampeding like
lemmings there's a cycle going on just
massive double cross because I really
used to be in into UFOs but the more you
look into UFOs it looks like and that's
another conspiracy government this whole
NASA deal and when he came to the
meeting he couldn't do it I knew this
guy well and then the next time he was
gonna meet with me his heart blew up it
blew up yeah like like a bomb like they
said his heart like completely ruptured
well the point is his name was Raymond T
and if you look at Mission Control he
was the main gommage and control to
control the cameras and everything
mm-hmm and he he was house he had
national security letters from the
president he'd run like secret
operations atma Cambodia and Laos he was
an Air Force engineer and he he knew the
whole deal and he would say what hold
they would say well he didn't meet with
you and tell you everything and he would
come and start gulping and he couldn't
get it out couldn't get what out he said
he was so threatened or whatever he
couldn't tell me about you think about
it probably he probably left laughs and
who's in the car sources are right there
were advanced technologies we were
worried the astronauts might die they
had two teams in orbit one with the real
ships this is not a joke Joe wait a
minute in an orbit and they were
communicating with Kennedy and the
government everybody and Nixon are gonna
have this giant thing about America's
number one and not have a backup plan at
the astronauts died put those headphones
back on lost your [ __ ] mind
hold on let him finish there tell me
what you're trying to say are you trying
to say that so the the United States
government Teague was gonna give me the
secret of NASA okay and then he couldn't
ever get it out a second program they
had a second program how do you know he
died he told me but before the heart
attack in the middle of the heart attack
hey I have a second ma'am no no I met
with him at the old sack command base
what did he actually tell you what
forward or not what what he told me he
said your murren Alice's resources
dead-on I was in control of the video
and radio communications he was two TVs
it's him on TV I mean it's the runner
that's very important to control are you
kidding
of course the the moon landings are you
kidding come on well you raised it you
want to know oh come on
that's ridiculous no but that's why I
don't trust the government that's why I
don't trust because they didn't want to
spend money they ran a fake up with just
re-entry devices and basic stuff in
space and did shoot some of it but then
they had a real mission that put the
reflectors everything on the moon with
no proof of that
so you believe well you know that the
the Russian government with Alex you
know that the Russian government you
know that the Russian government put
those laser sight those laser reflectors
on the moon as well with unmanned probes
yes you know that right so Alex you
think they definitely went to the moon
they're just the footage is fake is that
what you think yeah you can't bring film
back to the Van Allen radiation belt to
get spots all over right but we don't
have film what would lead us to believe
that they definitely did it because they
had RCA cameras well we trashed all the
amazing footage right this amazing
footage no circling launch in space in
case the real mission died so who's in
the fake one I'm not sure to show you
the real military advance okay okay but
man sir this Eddie so we got it we've
got to figure this out so what you're
saying is the one that we saw on TV with
Neil Armstrong one small step for man
that's all horseshit but the real one
actually took place they just couldn't
get the film back but Armstrong had been
on real missions so yes he definitely
been unreal missions but I don't know he
wouldn't tell me all of it he died
before we met the other dude I was next
day and his wife called my dad was
friends with him no no the other guy
what's his name okay Buzz Aldrin no Buzz
Aldrin yeah Buzz Aldrin said I want to
come on your show and I'm going into all
the heat oh he lives here in LA and one
time I ran into I'm gonna sleep with
that and he said I want to come on your
show and I said alright we'll come on
when it's the only interview he's
setting he goes I'm gonna tell you Alex
in your audience alone he said there is
an obelisk just like 2001 it's on the
moon of Mars the soul moan and it's
sending a transmission and it's all real
and it's all Egypt and there's aliens
everything else no he was real I think
useful how do you think he's full of
[ __ ] what if it's true
hey man if there is an obelisk on Mars I
think this really is communicating
obelisk on the moon of Mars the moon of
Mars Phobos
we gotta land there good lovin Instagram
let's give some people with their
habitation we can keep track if there's
something very important to be developed
from the moon I'm not sure what it is
right now of course you don't sure I
want to hear but I wanna hear what he
says first let's see what he says
yes yo hold it hold the go ahead Jim
America to make such gross expenditures
again for human habitation on the moon
we can help we can join with together we
can explore the moon and develop the
moon and steal tax money don't do it
together
Jan has not gone before is this where he
talks about the notes on my show yeah we
need to go and go to there's a monolith
there a very unusual structure this is
only little potato shaped object we need
four billion disclosers to come on once
in seven hours find out about that
they're gonna say who put that there
who put that there well the universe put
it there if you choose come God put it
there
we've come on wants four billion dollars
that's before me so that's the monolith
that thing that you're looking at wow
that's weird
I don't believe that [ __ ] for a second
okay let me tell you by Buzz Aldrin here
in Los Angeles and I can't tell you
anything else okay
look at this monolith on Phobos no weird
yeah that's like a weird structure who
knows that's a real picture that's
almost right yeah it's almost should
come on yeah oh that proves it yes
Robles I can I don't know [ __ ] about
Photoshop and I can make that okay I'm
sure you hear can I tell you the big
secret about my secret meeting with yes
let me hear the shitty fed you well no
Eddie don't slump
let's go communicate he told me that
Papa Smurf is real don't tell me what he
told me he told me he said you know
India's sending a probe to the moon and
they'll announce that when they crashed
the probe they found the undersea frozen
ice that covers the moon the moon has
dust on it it's a big water ball it's
gonna be the water we need to get off
the planet we make our big jump so the
whole point is no everything's laid on
the planet just perfect for Humanity we
make the steps right butts like a video
game buzzes [ __ ] no you're not listening
he's [ __ ] me give me a crash the
probe found exactly what they were
saying and I walked through an airport
look over and it says and it says India
discovers water on the moon that's all
water well they've definitely discovered
water on the moon right that's that's
bad but talking about it a year before
is that right good mice in my correct in
saying there's not water on the moon
Buzz Aldrin is he going to the meetings
and they tell him [ __ ] listen yeah he
went to look you want to go to every
meeting I don't get into all this stuff
okay I'm telling you Buzz Aldrin told me
in a year it's gonna be on the news that
they discovered water with a probe
they're sitting before they were even
sending a probe in the news they let
into your quote find it is the u.s.
already found it it's already been on
the moon that God knows how many times
the word is they got military
it's in the 50s what do you think we got
now so you think they have nuclear
minute they have bases on the moon well
I'll never get into all this stuff right
don't do that but let's just say it's
super advanced so you really think they
have some sort of a base out there
that's so far away why wouldn't they
just do it on the desert somewhere what
is this mi P detected water on the moon
way back in June huh they're dropping
dis info on your house huh Buzz Aldrin
tells me they're gonna announce India
finds water oh my god buzz I'll follow
him on Instagram and then come back to
me with the moon look at this the moon
impact probe which class crash-landed at
a designated site on the lunar South
Pole on November 14 2008 had picked up
some clear signatures of water to
educate 5-minutes dislike crashing yeah
mr. Nair said at a press conference here
on Friday
interesting hey you know what when it
comes to space Alex that's not your
forte
aye aye but one one thing I want to ask
gram what's up with but amazing it's
amazing how so he's just like he's a
he's oh he's so into it
did you see when the guy comes over he
goes you're full of crap he ruins the
money just punches him yeah hey check
this out I wanted to ask you what are
you what do you think is Trump gonna do
anything about the stratosphere I can't
get to you the points do you want mean
you know what do you think Trump wants
to stop that I'm gonna write it down
right right but down the next question
I'll do it here that's the question
question you just before the Alex Jones
is off the rails right get the joke oh I
don't have to write it down I didn't get
it because you've been dead
we'll Trump is from that program to stop
well woody what do you think the program
is and what do you think the program the
director of the CIA is John Oh brandy
talking about strategies about
strategies song injections it's gonna
cost ten billion dollars a year and
there's gonna be some countries opposed
to it because it's gonna mess up the web
telling me about atmosphere I'm talking
about stratospheric geo challenge si I
I've never heard of that it's a super
important when you can break it down to
three letters John O Brennan admitted in
June of 2016 I'm not bashing you but you
entertain so many jokes about it which I
get because a lot of its BS there is an
entire atmospheric terraforming
geoengineering manipulation they don't
call it chemtrails and of course the CIA
director admitted they have this huge
program Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation owns the major patents on it
from Westinghouse and others they use
these big antennas to manipulate the
weather they can like China is like
causing huge iron like HAARP like hard
ology it's all Declassified you think
HAARP manipulates the whether they admit
it does I used to have the head of HAARP
general bitten cape art not all the time
but exactly there's giant weather
modification systems and there's weather
wars between different governments and
they it's all d-class explain to people
that are listening what HAARP is what
does it stand for high-altitude
something yeah they've got a system that
supposedly well you know what HAARP
really was under its classification what
does it stand for high frequency active
auroral research program so the idea
behind this was they wanted to do
research on the aurora and didn't they
want to see if they could communicate
using it and send a radio wave radar
right yeah that and they also wanted to
be able to send radio signals to places
where they wouldn't make transit really
go what does that have to do with
stratospheric aerosol and doesn't really
go into the atmosphere
well the secrets I've interviewed
ahead of it okay okay how does harp work
with the chemtrails what do they let
goes okay
only a micronic amount a small amount of
what HAARP does is in the atmosphere
it's bouncing off the aurora borealis
and then resonating back through in a
deep earth communication program to
satellites and other things through the
planet so it's suppose you communicate
to satellites through the satellites
down to submarines so here goes this is
an actual definition how HAARP works the
facility's transmitters and the radio
waves let's just read it first waves
upwards into the ionosphere between 100
350 kilometres of altitude the resulting
heating effect creates irregularities in
the electron density there which in turn
allows communication signals as from
satellites to be relayed off the
ionosphere that's not what it really
does then they can shoot the satellite
frequency coded through the earth to
submarines now what is this website from
there the sensation buoy you want the
real stuff I'll tell you yeah sure okay
let me explain something okay I got
contacted about 10 years ago and they
said the head of the heart project
really likes your work he liked to come
on interviews online and he liked to
come on in everybody and about 30
minutes in a Colonel came on the line
and said sorry during a break and cut
the guy off whoa Tom Tom Tom I mean this
really happens to spooky music huge
spooky music back I believe you that's
true I want to know I want to know that
I want another relationship become
trails have to do do you think Trump is
gonna look into the si a project that
the CIA has greenlit he is starting out
with vaccines as I told people he would
do investigating all the damage they've
caused oh there's another ultimately
that's good to start the vaccines get
that [ __ ] together too for sure but what
about the s AI programs that the CIA has
greenlit
you think he's gonna get into that yeah
I think it's next level she said we
won't even communicate with these
microphones it's gonna be like
you're so locked on to this it's like
here's the problem with all this si si a
[ __ ] most of what you see when you see
those jets flying around those clouds
behind them most of that is just a jet
engine exactly the German fuses that
with the real reason what's the real
program well here's the thing you're
right and so is Joe because the world's
complex there are secret and quasi
secret and public programs to test
manipulation of the weather and weather
systems the Arabs are doing that the
Chinese are doing it the Russians are do
the people being cloud seeding for
weather manipulation but they're doing
it for different purposes and that not
to the head of the u.s. weather weapon
program for 27 years on my show first as
I saw was he classified I saw the news
of the panhandle of Texas
I called him running a major cloud
seeding company with his son and got the
nine-year-old to Austin and then after
that he totally freaked out because the
CIA came to his house do you want the
interviews on YouTube do you want to
know what he said yes
he was a world war ii fighter pilot and
i said the end of world war ii he flew
the first planes into hurricanes well
which which are in the atlantic
that's pretty gangsta and into typhoons
that are even faster in the pacific and
then he and then he also much squadrons
in vietnam flooding everything up to 10
feet of water out of clear blue skies
within hours what about it with wid
their with their chemicals you have to
be to do that super badass fly into a
hurricane or a typhoon he's gotta do it
holy [ __ ] anyways a super badass I mean
oh he's alive he's been living at 90 he
was still all there and I thought it not
even kicked my ass Big Texan I feel like
I wasn't the guy was tougher than me
anyways so so we're sitting there and he
gives me all this data and I can't
believe it he's gonna be all these
classified photos and stuff because they
just Declassified the file and no one
thought to call the old man from Lubbock
or whatever it was Brian so I call him
out get him on they send a bunch of
people to their company and threatened
them the next week after aired it and he
let it out he said in 1967 we certified
at the Stanford Research Institute that
he was able to control hurricanes create
hurricanes and steer hurricanes all that
got black budgeted shut down and then
they got into these arrays where they
could use
and out of that and Westinghouse came
came the the the whole heart program so
in the 60s they could create control and
steer or kill hurricanes that's why you
Google now Bill and Melinda Gates bought
all those patents and the quote Bill
Gates is gonna save the world from bad
weather
Bill Gates wants to stop hurricanes
Google so I so let me ask is the weather
machine let me pause for a second how
does the how do they manipulate a
hurricane so the Hurricanes gonna happen
how they break it up okay if it's if
it's if it's coming into lands their
problem with with aerial arrays
projecting into the sky they can break
it up or strengthen it or kill it or
steer it its own that he's doing that
with HAARP well they've got they've got
heart bases all over the place they call
them Doppler radar facilities oh the
government wants your local city to have
Doppler radar I thought that was like so
you could house a guy in front of the
screen that's it like 1/10 of 1% they
can crank those or raise up that have
mass up your lights might go out when
they do it a little bit really yeah
because they'll use the whole power of
your town through the Doppler radars
then they control it the US has a giant
weather weapon hidden in front of
everybody in every town in city and poor
Russians and Chinese are just
discovering at all the US has one of the
weapons that could knock them all out
right can bill gates control the weather
ideas for barges to pump cold water from
the depth of the ocean to create some
sort of a roadblock for the hurricane
since hurricanes pull power from the
waters warm temperatures cooling the
water could have theoretically dismantle
the hurricane well it sounds like a good
idea though sound like a genius ID spray
cold water and currents rails John O
Brennan in the front of the CFR is
saying we're doing this because for
global warming and we gotta say you are
you are about about geoengineering and
chemtrails you were wrong about the
dinosaurs not being wrong but hey what
about that there they're coming out
saying hey there's gonna be some
countries that that are that aren't
gonna be for it and we got to figure out
how we're gonna deal with them because
yes what's the big stimulation keep
going with that come on man don't change
the subject keep going with that you're
not done with
imagine it's good you're here but
imagine me and Joe actually Joe come on
got me off on you want me here about
Ronald Reagan - don't you later finish
the essay I Pro he doesn't know about
this
what do you know about the essay I
program look let's get this done when
most of the real programs are just like
fronts for something else is not even
real so you don't think they're spraying
[ __ ] into the atmosphere no there is a
program for geoengineering there's a
program in place and yes said it's the
Doppler radar system and HAARP and what
else and an aerial sprayings still the
most effective and then what do they do
they do have Pat when you say aerial
spraying where they spraying barium
salts alumina oxide a radioactive
isotopes there's some rain them in the
air doing that because because it does a
bunch of things they're testing a bunch
of stuff they're they're manipulating
things listen our Pentagon why do you
have evidence that they're doing this
and spraying aluminum barium whatever
online and read the Department of Energy
it's all public just like he just need
to go online and watch the Chinese dude
get jacked by a tiger great that's out
there you know the Department of Energy
gov right and you can watch CFR CIA
director at the time Brennan admitting
all this this is all public yeah he
talked about but he no I saw it I saw
the video we could play the video and go
over it if you want but he's talking
about various options for controlling
global warm yeah they're laying out the
future look if global warming there's a
hold on a second if global warming is
real we know it is right don't you think
they would have you don't believe global
warming is real they keep measuring
these temperatures and scientists keep
saying well let's found out let's find
out what's real okay I believe that high
it goes cold
there's always micro temperature he's
always changed that's taxes Al Gore
won't fix it okay I think we all agree
there's shifts but what I'm saying is
there absolutely is global warming right
what does this house when my dad was a
kid the 1950s for 3-4 months out of the
year it was below zero or freezing you
had to chop wood
he'd freeze your ass off in all houses
had even the south have had
you'll had all sorts of chimneys in them
for fireplaces because it was freezing
cold right and now there has been a
warming period but that's part of a
normal global cycle based on the Sun all
these astrophysicists are sure the whole
thing about claiming it's the carbon we
put out the earth is carbon star if
there's a carbon cycle well that's the
big story I want to get to the globalist
want to tax if they can tax oxygen
carbon dioxide water or sunlight they
have total control over the whole
lifecycle of the planet let's play the
video let's play the video this this CIA
a guy talking about it because what I
inferred from it is they come up with
some sort of solutions if global warming
becomes a giant renin is a freakin
unknown hobbyist global warming it's a
good question what do they have to do I
don't know what the CIA does do you know
the Central Intelligence Agency they
were built to stop the spread of
communists right but it's an
Intelligence Agency that the part of the
environment okay they're a part of the
intelligence community and if they got
hired I would imagine this is just me
guessing right off the top of my head if
they got hired to assess a threat and a
threat being from global warming like
what what do we have to worry about are
we really gonna lose cities do we really
have a nation
give George Soros to the UN total power
for a 100 trillion per decade global tax
to micromanage and surveil everything
humans do let's see if carbons toxic
they've got a surveillant thus they have
a jurisdictional controller lives
okay hold up why does it say debunked
CIA director admits chemtrails
geoengineering stratospheric aerosol
injections so it says the crime hold on
at the council admits geoengineering in
the form of stratospheric aerosol
injections s AI is taking a place ie
temperature is taking place ie
chemtrails and the rebuttal is nowhere
in his speech is there an admission that
an s AI program is already taking place
the part where Brennan mentions
geoengineering is just one example out
of several not often mentioned issues
the CIA monitors for potential elements
of instability in the world
asai program if ever implemented could
penetrate conflicts and security threats
if misused the CIA's job is to consider
all types of concepts
concepts for potential future problems
and threats including the science
oriented concepts that's totally fine so
let me break down right but isn't that
possible we're gonna buddy but what that
guy just said is that possible no that's
basically what Brennan said boys saying
is that there are potential threats you
were mentally it's an issue right so
he's not admitting that he had there's
an essay I tell you okay go ahead tell
me
everybody debates how many programs
there are all the specifics a lot of
that's classified
you can google China lodges major
weather control operations ten years
right or Qatar does it or Saudi Arabia
or the UK or sure people have studied
know know that right no there's they
call it study
there's a giant hell in 2005 the
Department of Energy program for aerosol
testing was five million dollars a year
so under u.s. code title fit be chapter
32 subsection one thousand thousand 28
paragraph B is that true you nailed that
right yes yes under US code that was
Jamie right it up
Jewish code title 50 chapter that's it
faster remember u.s. code title 50
subsection 128 the real fast brain
homework that's me effect speed speech
game it's a it's like one pot Jesus
yours there's restrictions on use of
human subjects for testing of chemtrails
we'll go back go back back there you go
or biological agents alright now what
they do in this though is they say it's
illegal to test unless it's for research
reason to kill people it was for
research purpose you know that's how
some of those Japanese Whaler vessels
get away with killing whales still they
say it's for research purpose exactly
and they kill the whales and sell them
from dark [ __ ] engineers I'm gonna give
you the big secret man if you're us I do
I'm not kidding around
I know I'm not either thing it's a man
they call their the high priest they're
scientists
right they're engineers they're allowed
to kill people test stuff on kids and
jet black people with syphilis but all
the Declassified stuff because they are
scientists all the real executioner's
torturers or most of them are people
making decisions or doctors and so it's
all medical doctor stuff in this big
breakaway civilization of scientists
okay and so that's what they've built it
under under under research provisions
they can even kill anybody they want
alright I'm gonna go back because we
took Eddie's turn on chemtrails but we
did it to sidetrack from what you were
saying about the moon and I want to go
back to what you're saying because you
were saying that there was two
completely different missions and one of
them was real and that there was some
sort of contact with aliens no I was
getting better I'm saying I had a ties
that was you're implying it's not well
let's just say that okay blowing I was
told by top NASA individual Raymond
Teague that indeed there was a breakaway
program and that he heard and saw
transmissions
on some back channels of real feeds and
advanced ships that he'd never even seen
that basically didn't even look like
there were anything that he could
imagine that was classified and he knew
about some classified programs for every
program you saw there was at least ten
programs that were secret that submitted
about NASA 90% secret or more and so he
knew about a cloud bunch classified
programs and he was seeing transmissions
and things coming back and talk to
people about a whole breakaway program
they sent that was a lot safer a lot
bigger than the moon then they had guys
up in orbit just basically so that even
other foreign governments from the
trajectory point would think they were
getting transmissions back from the moon
so they had people out basically out
outside of the regular orbit we just go
around in circles whereas a
geosynchronous we're in one spot right
transmitting back from a mathematical
spot to look like transmissions to fool
the Russians and everybody all the real
mission was going on on the moon so you
believe they went to the moon do you
think that it was Buzz Aldrin and I
don't know Neil Armstrong tell me
everything he died hmm he said I'm gonna
meet with you tomorrow and he died dude
that's like a movie he told me I'm ready
I'm gonna tell you everything and then
he was just totally it was crazy but he
did admit to you that what the public
got was faked
yeah well there's some footage from the
moon that looks so ridiculous and most
people have never seen that there's some
footage of them that here's here's the
big speculation this is one of the
really big ones failing is that there
was a lot of footage that they did where
they were doing tests that they wound up
just using for press releases they using
like to say this is actual footage other
stuff for the project because they
wanted to be guaranteed of it they had a
real yeah but there was a thing with
Michael Collins in Gemini 15 there was a
test photo of him with like a test rig
on and it was like suspended and you can
see the background behind him it was
clearly too suspended on wires and they
took that same photo and blacked it out
and used it as a press photo of him on
an actual spacewalk but it's the same
exact yo these are stuff yeah they do
that where they just go over it with it
back down you see you actually use an
exacto knife here's the thing my dad
when he was just like a junior in high
school was in the plan to program at UT
and they already had cd-roms and
computers and they had a nuclear plant
under UT nobody knew about and my dad
told me about this when I was a teenager
and I would like later go the library
couldn't find it and that googled it
it's not even really in the news but
I've gone to UT and talked to him they
go yeah you know about the reactor the
building of reactor
yeah the awesomes got and then and then
no one even knew that Austin has two
nuclear reactors in North Austin what
yeah but the point was my that was for
you that was after he was in college
they built is a reactor under which
building in Austin Texas it's it's big
it's a big railway system under there
but it's it's built right under it right
under like I said gesture so there's a
nuclear reactor in Austin Texas how many
people know about this you know it's in
the literature my dad gently about it
when I was a kid I thought you I mean I
believe my dad my dad told me about a
Dallas hospital it was killing people
for their organs and like six years
later I saw it on 60 minutes why it's
yeah they were killing people for a
workings yep really I might have told me
about that in Dallas it was on 60
minutes yeah my dad said I was 16 or 15
taken driver's course she said don't
sound that organ donor card I know
hospitals that kill you Jesus and I said
dad you're kidding us now I've
he was an oral surgeon and rewired jaws
he's not heard this one kills people all
time that is this is one of the
creepiest things you've ever you might
give me I imagine doctors that get
kickbacks for organs that kind of let
their patients are seen as the highest
caste by the elite so they're the ones
pulling all the stuff I'm telling you
man you know creepy it would be like to
find out that a nurse that you were
working with was killing people but
that's the story that happens over and
over again so crazy smart killer it's
been a bunch know these nurses nurses
decide they don't want to take care of
somebody they poison them they they have
someone maybe someones dying slow and
they don't like it and they just like
get tired of dealing with their poles oh
yeah a lot of the times they're sadistic
there's been a lot of you're worse than
I am about facts you're absolutely on
target everything everything I know and
you're on target you pretend you're not
knowing all this you knew that document
off the top of your head like that
syringe you must have been obsessed with
chemtrails right no I know crazy mine's
about thirty-five and now it's not good
anymore he steals that from you stuff I
remember but I I want to tell you guys
the big enchilada the big enchilada well
the problem is when we don't have
headphones on we talk over each other
it's hard when three people were talking
you know just you know it's none of our
fault
it's just natural at a conspiracy you're
you are Bill Hicks huh no I was younger
than him totally different hungry I love
how I've had success it's all Bill Hicks
he was a funny guy but give me a freakin
break man listen to those the families
call me before him said please stop the
people saying you're Bill Hicks control
these damn people don't worry about that
put the headphones back on fine so I
need to know I need to know what do you
know about aliens and how are aliens
real all right look this is really big
so okay
yeah pouring on the shot of the media at
the South problem now the question is
what does Donald Trump know about
anything oh yeah what does he know now
right because he's in the office I don't
know no it's that would be the first
thing I think the Joe Rogan experience
deserves that
first thing I did I would run to the
office and that go who's got the
documents
who's got the alien documents who's got
him who's got him that would be the
first thing I would want to know right
cheers sir all right let me give you my
best please deep research approximation
what do you think it's going but am I
wrong to still hold out hope that aliens
are real because I tell you has one of
two guilty pleasures that I still cling
to as Bigfoot and aliens those are two
Bigfoot not so much I wish it was real
but I just don't are you ready yes
Bigfoot's room
no come on daddy no are you ready yes
I'm gonna give you the big Joe they're
aliens in this room right now for real
yeah you're not of this world bro me
you're the alien oh wow I didn't know
it's like there was like an old comic
book about that about some dude who was
a forgetful professor then you realized
at the end of it he was actually an
alien from another planet that scene
sent down here to monitor people he just
forgot well here's what the elite
believed and let me be very clear the
video takes out context I only go with
what I can prove oh thank you and people
can't even handle that okay I'm really
surprised how much you knew every angle
of so called pizza gate that I even
forgot well it's to meet well obviously
we both have children and when you hear
about someone that wants to molest
children it's a special kind of evil
it's a special kind of uro
and it's and it's also a special kind of
bizarre twisted sickness that the human
mind put like is is capable of latching
on it's a horse of programming to take
care of kids that'd be nice to them
there's something very crazy about
people's brains and it's fun something
very crazy about the the weird variables
that can potentially happen I agree you
know all sorts of weird crazy
aberrations in standard behavior you
know like this the standard behavior a
bunch of people that are just normal
folks you got kids I got kids oh it gets
the kids together for a playdate you sit
down you have a couple of beers you
laugh you joke have a good night Bob
good night Steve that's [ __ ] normal
[ __ ] right when you're normal and
there's normal people around you you
assume that everybody is basically a
good person we all have our problems
normal is your wife comes in the
room she get going you don't look at a
five-year-old think that's what I want
no there's some yeah you try to say is
there some people out there that have
this horrific programming whatever the
[ __ ] it is that causes it as a bunch of
psychologists trying to speculate and
figure out what causes but if they need
to be beaten the head with a ball-peen
hammer if the thing is it's real and
it's it's terrifying candidates going on
we can't deny it's real and it's also
like [ __ ] [ __ ] Jared from Subway the
subway guy the subway guys in jail for
being a pedophile
they team up team up and they usually
have high intelligence and there's
armies we're fighting a pedophile
conspiracy but beyond that it's a
vampire conspiracy and that they are
inter-dimensionally sucking the essence
of our youth right and they believe
they're possessed by an offworld entity
they do yeah and then Joe I've been on
air 22 years I don't get into aliens
metaphysical religion any of that I've
studied the elite and I've also
communicate with a lot of the top people
and then and if you want to know I will
actually break down right now the best
knowledge right now what's happening on
the planet what's happening let me give
you a basic gist Alton okay I love when
you can use that word with full
confidence I've never said that let me
give you a basic gist alt I feel like oh
my god I'm such a fraud no you're not
you know but that's what I think if I
use that word now you'll get all this
you already have most Atticus you're a
bookworm a research worm in a good way
the elite are all about transcendence
and living forever and the secrets of
the universe and they want to know all
this some are good some are bad some are
a mix but the good ones don't ever want
to organize the bad ones didn't want to
organize because they lost have for
power powerful consciousnesses don't
want to dominate other people they want
to empower them so they don't tend to
get together until things are really
late in the game then they come together
evils always defeated because good is so
much stronger and we're on this planet
and Einstein's physics showed at max
Planck's it says shut it all there's at
least twelve dimensions and now that's
all the top scientists and in
billionaires are coming out saying it's
a false hologram it is artificial the
computers are scanning and finding
tension points where it's artificially
projected and gravity's bleeding in to
this universe that's what they call dark
matter so we're like a thought or a
dream that's a wisp in some computer
programs some gods mind whatever they're
proving it all it's all coming out now
there's like this sub transmission zone
but love the third dimension that's just
turned over the most horrible things
what it resonates to and it's trying to
get up into the third dimension that's
just a basic level consciousness to
launch into the next levels and our
species is already way up in the fifth
sixth dimension consciously our best
people but there's this big war trying
to like basically destroy humanity
because humanity has free will and
there's a decision to which level we
want to go to we have free will so evils
allowed to come and contend not just
good and the elites themselves believe
they're racing well using human
technology to try to take our best minds
and build some type of breakaway
civilization where they're gonna merge
with machines transcend and break away
from the failed species of his man which
is kind of like a false transmission
because they're thinking what they are
is ugly and bad projecting it onto
themselves instead of believing no it's
a human test about building us up and so
Google was set up
1819 years ago this was I know about
this before it was Declassified I'm just
saying I've good sources that they
wanted to build a giant artificial
system and Google believes that the
first artificial intelligence will be a
supercomputer
based on the neuron activities of the
hive mind of humanity with billions of
people wired into the internet of
sayings and so all of our thoughts go
into it and we're actually building a
computer that has real neurons in real
time that's also psychically connected
to us that are organic creatures so that
they will have current prediction powers
future prediction powers a true crystal
ball but the big secret is once you have
a crystal ball and know the future you
can add stimuli beforehand and make
decisions that control the future and so
then it's the end of consciousness and
free will for individuals as we know and
a true 2.0 in a very bad way hive mind
consciousness with an AI jacked into
everyone knowing our hopes and dreams
delivering it to us not in some PKD wire
head system where we plug in and give up
on consciousness because of a limited
pleasure but because we were already
didn't absorbed before we knew it by
giving over our consciousness to the
system our daily decisions that it was
able to manipulate and control into a
larger system there's now a human
counter-strike taking place to shut this
off before it gets fully into place and
to block these systems and to try to
have an actual debate about where
humanity goes and cut off the pedophiles
and psychic vampires that are control of
this AI system before humanity's
destroyed wait a minute humanity has
only controlled of AI I think it had the
pedophiles getting control pet the
pedophiles whatever rule the devil
whatever you wanna call it this
interdimensional thing that gives them
advanced offworld technology the Fallen
one the son of this world is giving them
advanced knowledge what on astronomist
um's what is already been used before on
other populations what that's Satan but
what are you talking about let's say
explain that you did something that you
know the stupid preacher tells you about
who's totally controlled or something
you read about on you know in the news
or TV right this is an interdimensional
force that wants to influence us to
build something that absorbs us and
kills us rather than the divine freewill
we're given to build something much
better than in powers of the species so
the species is now making a decision
well you came out as it's our future
what are you getting this from from
that's what it is but what are you
getting into no from the from looking at
all the data researching and studying
and watching the enemy that's the big
decision that humanity has now got
before us so if you were directing
someone to investigate this on their own
how would they do that so if you say hey
here's the problem you get some place
finally in deep research where it's what
every culture already said what
everybody already knew what they're
telling you movies like Prometheus what
the elite admit the New York Times they
believe in is this you know seated by
offworld systems panspermia yes
everything everything they're doing
points towards this and then you read
their own writings who they believe
we're this ugly fallen ugly species
we're only to be killed they're the rich
billionaires who are better than us and
they're gonna merge with machines and
become gods and go the next level don't
you think that most people who
extrapolate from where we stand today
with our cell phones and our Apple
watches and our integration with the
computer and the internet constantly
don't you think that most people see
that there's gonna be some sort of
symbiotic connection it's a very easy
thing that we're saying it before I
understand but a lot of people were
saying it was a problem who engineered
what we were given what is the point of
the back doors the trojan horses he
hears engineer who engineered what
here's the elite the elite literally
believed inter-dimensionally they were
given this information and then built it
and here's the thing they built it and
Google admits even at data dumps to
Wired two years ago that they're
building an AI that will end human
consciousness free will and take over
and the next species will rise out of
that they've already decided our species
but people have been taught Marshall
McLuhan was talking about that 50
[ __ ] years ago
here's the old they built it amazon two
years ago admits they can already with
99% certainty pick what their regular
users are gonna order Alex before they
hold on a second instead of dragging
this out to some nefarious end isn't it
entirely possible that all these
futurists all these technological
innovators they all see the same endgame
if there's going to be some sort of a
complete integration between people but
it's the artificial intelligence on that
historically everybody saw this coming
right and so this big all the futurists
all the people that study the most fort
before silicon chips were created the
Marshall McLuhan I think it was in the
1970s said that human beings are the sex
organs of the machine world and he was
saying even back then that human beings
are eventually going to integrate or
become something that's a part what I'm
telling you is there's a centralized
system of what they're building but is
it naturally occurring so is that where
artificial who's doing the elites
believe they're getting offworld he's
building these things you're just
describing right now I mean if you
actually read with all the global is
saying you've obviously read the writers
you know this show they are getting not
off world but interdimensional
communications to then build this system
that we see lowers our IQ makes us live
less I've never but when you're making
these big statements they they're
getting interdimensional signals is
telling them to create these systems
that lower IQs that's something you got
to really prove like if there's okay
please if there's something you can show
all the
show screen time all the computers
lowering IQ is blowing fertility okay
right there is that a case is that a
case of is somebody holding a gun to
your head let me tell you about me I'm
addicted this goddamn thing I love
watching my videos I love love taking
pictures of [ __ ] I love looking
interface with humanity there's a lot of
beautiful things it does but I'll tell
you if they're very addictive they're
very addictive
[ __ ] hold on a second let me stop
you right there I don't necessarily
think that's engineered to be addictive
I think it's engineered to be really
well and the fact work really well and
the fact that it works really well is
very addictive just like little kids
look at a screen you put a [ __ ]
television in front of them when they're
one-year-old and play some stupid
commercial and they're like whoa Joe
they try to frame a second know they
hold on a second they made better and
better technology that we're not
designed to absorb human beings have
exactly set we have the exact same DNA
that we did 10,000 years ago lamb GMO
and there was nothing like television
there was nothing like movies there was
nothing like stereo headphones and
projector listen don't shine please go
on you're crazy like a child Morley's
you're interrupting my crazy rant I'm
telling you that this is a natural
progression of this massive and fashion
that we have with technology they don't
have to engineer it it's natural it
happens to you and anybody who's looking
at cooler and cooler special effects in
movies all that stuff is a natural Steve
Jobs wouldn't let his kids play with an
iPad well then he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
let your kids play the guy [ __ ] wrong
that was right Ram I'm not disagreeing
with no you interrupted it ten times you
[ __ ] oh I'm done no [ __ ] we're not
talking about the weather Eddie tell you
that right now let me tell you right now
yeah let me tell you shut up to control
okay what I'm telling you're talking
about the elites and interdimensional
signals of the receiving that are
telling us to lower our IQ you can't
just say that I need proof okay let me
give you proof that sounds so crazy by
the way I'm area yeah all that sounds so
crazy I wonder where the aliens are the
proof the honor you know what it's
really cool to say
computer simulations but it talks about
that everyone says you're not nobody's
aliy easily the job yeah we're a
computer simulation but then when you
talk about interdimensional like magical
[ __ ] exactly magic is a technology that
hasn't been discovered yet
exactly videos are [ __ ] magic for
sure yeah if I can you know we you and I
could do this right now and we could go
like here we'll do it right now this is
what's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go right now you want to talk some magic
because this really is [ __ ] magic
we're gonna do Instagram live okay right
now we're doing Instagram live we're
doing like one of those little Instagram
stories instantaneous ever wash cause
this is a whole new this is a whole new
thing young Jaime am i right [ __ ] this
is never live yeah but I got you go a
little longer than you let me go these
light weights I'm taking coffee
I drank one of these kill Clif coffees I
drank one order of butter coffee this is
gone I'm drinking this Erewhon do this
conspiracy I'm drinking some juice I had
two glasses of whiskey that's [ __ ]
and these [ __ ] are peeing they keep
peeing understand something I take
credit that was his rant I'm not sure
we're gonna go back to that he's
definitely high as [ __ ] did this stuff
about telling him some [ __ ] exactly
crazy [ __ ] I knew that was the key the
key to make this podcast super special
was well he asked for the whiskey
himself so he started the post that's
his oh that's ours no that's ours
jazzing live listeners this is just a
wrapper yeah a big time record yeah
gentlemen Jack is this is a sentence
that's right it's good I mean good and
it
tastes terrible tastes like you know
you're sucking on the devil's [ __ ]
disgusting mean that's kinda half the
fun of whiskey is that it's disgusting a
lot of people thought that this was a
conspiracy because Eddie went live on
Instagram live and you disappeared so
there was a lot of talk online never
existed globalist are human they think
we're a bunch of dumb animals
where are the aliens they're carrying
out a shot they believe it's not aliens
does that have to do with the Luciferian
Freemasonry type [ __ ]
I love bones skull and bones break down
free cuz I know in the Albert Pike wrote
the Freemason Bible he's talking about
Luciferian go for it go for it tell me
about Albert Albert Pike and I want to
get me Joe here's the thing Joe you
brought in right this way your point
about it'll lead to your point cuz you
brought wine you brought the whole booze
do this first please you brought the
whole point about no more weed Alex you
went too deep here showing the smoke
seriously I wanna be nice great guy look
I Love You Man what I'm telling you is
is that the globalist admit a lot of
this it's in a lot of their white papers
all the reports we're going to actually
give it to you I will okay they say they
believe they're gonna become gods the
rest of us are profane well they've [ __ ]
about interdimensional beings giving
them all the data you you know where the
theory of the species and where all the
Darwin stuff came from where he had a
hallucination and believed he was given
all this stuff from like demons and I'm
not saying you confusing Darwin
Descartes no no that's Darwin didn't
Descartes have it isn't he the one that
came up with the idea of scientists
science from a dream
what Darwin's idea keep it down
they believe and you sit there and show
to Darwin tell you know you probably
already know that I know that Darwin's
partner the guy that he developed a
theory of evolution where there were
they both had like a similar theory and
holding together with it and he was like
really into it to the point where he was
into channeling and all sorts of weird
stuff he knows this discredited him
Radiolab that's what they believe I'm
saying it's real Shannon's gonna have me
up here old clip together that's what
I'm saying I'm saying they discredited
him they just put all the emphasis on
Darwin that's why you only know about
Darwin whatever it all came from
freemason well then that's phase two I
do we do start there we're just [ __ ]
around you don't have to do a show like
this very oh that's great I love it I'm
a man okay just tell you please do news
time if you look at this that's what I'm
telling you I don't believe it
okay I'm telling you studying what the
establishment believes none of them are
atheists they all believe they're
getting interdimensional stuff see if
you go back to Galton's
and Wedgwood and Huxley recognize always
modern names if you go back to Darwin
Darwin wrote this these letters
república read these online from a
national you know Royal archives in
England stuff they all believed they
were all part of a secret breeding
program where the British thought they
would have like this superhuman if they
bred these six families together to like
create all this is like mainline British
history this is known as an accessory
and then Dalton who's related to all
these other guys in the 1850s he starts
having these ideas he says there's a
double helix which is the snake
for science and medicine and he said
we're gonna discover the keys and the
building blocks to life and he said it's
gonna be called biometrics and we'll
track everybody by reading their
genetics it's what Hitler freaked out
about and picked up and something like
eight of the 14 new Sciences like half
are more than half the sciences that
came since the 1860s were all from
gulten and all from Darwin so the media
and the Liberals gave me this one thing
you know origin of the species like
unless think it's wrong or right it's
super heavy like galactic stuff they
give this to you this is only one little
blowdown Bs thing we need to have you go
to what these guys really wrote they
were like intermarrying and involved in
wicked seances and channeling and all
this weird-ass crap and then they
envisioned okay there's a double helix
DNA discovered it okay biometrics okay
world government okay computers
okay atomic weapons give me the
equations and they were like all then
like going to other scientists meetings
and go we believe there's a program
where you take different matter together
in isotopes it'll cause an explosion and
it's like they were like given either
humans or super advanced already had
this knowledge from somewhere else in
our genetics and we're here before and
we're able to then manifest this their
genetic memories and archetypes or it
was given offworld but humans like have
all this data compacted and compress
ready like programs what's that called
like the Akashic records or something
like that and so if people ate all of it
is is is is Akashic and epigenetics
here's the epigenetics they'll take
chickens with eggs and do ten
generations and major universities that
have never seen a hawk and they put them
in these like these 20-foot ceilings and
they'll have a triangle fly over and a
square fly over and the little baby
chickens never care generation after
generation go on for 15 years they fly
one Hawk over and they all squawk
yelling screaming and run into their
nest now they never saw a hawk I never
saw killer chicken generation after
generation whisk it was compressed data
knowledge of the hawk that is passed on
genetically yeah they say that's why
children are always afraid of monsters
it goes no my Gerson bear I used to be
cat my son just wants to be chased so
much he wants to practice getting away
from a predator he loves
the most he wants to get away you can't
catch me predators you can't fight if
you can get the [ __ ] away from that
tiger at the zoo in China I recommend
you do that yeah I'll admit that I was
like oh [ __ ] we shouldn't let him smoke
weed but then now you think we run back
down bring back you cream back strong
keep it going you're gonna do good place
right now
keep it going you're talking about now
you're getting into Albert Pike ooh well
he's the founder of the KKK Confederate
General head of the Illuminati worldwide
at that time so let's establish
something that's like maybe people that
are listening to this Michael what in
the [ __ ] of these guys ramble about
let's establish this throughout history
from the beginning of organized humans
secret knowledge folks don't wanna pass
knowledge or there's also been people
conspiring to control whatever its
assigned but and people conspiring to
control whatever aspect of it whether
its political whether it's the military
like whatever it is there's always been
that it's always happened there's been
military cooze all throughout history
there's been Wars all throughout the
United States just had a peaceful one
bro how so I mean dude the intelligence
community leaked all the data to bring
down the globalist Russian intelligence
community leaked all what data they
leaked all the way he leaks he's over
here saying we broke so he was saying
that the Russians didn't do it no really
how do you know this because the
mainstream media said I mean Joe give me
a break I know I know I just want to
know how you know have you ever if you
know me for like 16 17 years yes you
ever done me to say I have a source that
I'm making it up be honest no no no I
mean I've got sources though so you
can't tell us how you know let's just
say I got data today from a head of
state and what do you say I can tell you
okay don't tell me the point is you
didn't tell me you know but the frames
we screwed up and released it early so
cause the problem explained the whole
Russian diversion we didn't mean on
purpose that's always mad at us bust out
with that Russian thing because there's
intelligent people like my students
like you hear that you don't believe the
Russians had to wear so why you saying
believe that yeah why you saying that
the Intelligence Agency leaked all this
and not Russia because I was told before
it was all leaked by the former director
of psychological operations the CIA it
was gonna come out he told you that was
gonna be leaked yeah before I was never
like in bed with the CIA I've
interviewed people from the CIA NSA
defense intelligence you name it over
the years I mean it's all over the news
but it's an entirely possible little
flynn former head of defense
intelligence tweets all my articles I'm
not telling you it's some secret I mean
letting enemy knows the point is is that
I'm seen as an honest good person that
understand what's going on I'm out for
humanity
I don't want personal power I want to
help people but isn't it entirely
possible I mean like how does it
information like that get out well
there's an open rebellion against the
criminals that hijacked our government
and so we overthrew the globalists and
Obama and we're taking him over in
France in Italy in Spain in Greece in
the UK the only place we're not
successful so far is Canada so you just
took Australia and bio it took Australia
with the I got Murray on the Society
what does that man see most people sit
there and brag about stuff I'm telling
you what's really going on Australia I
mean globalist are losing countries
every month right now to the Liberty
mobile what what says that they're these
are people you and your family to be
successful and aren't out to hurt you to
make you poor like the globalist there's
good people and they used the
intelligence agencies to defeat the
globalist and there's been a major
counter-offensive and the globalist made
one wrong move it happened five years
ago it was it was the system-wide leak
four years ago I've had CIA
whistleblowers all Obama show Colonels
and Special Operations you name it who
were authorized by high-level senators
come on my show
they ran a counter-coup there was a deal
made with radical Islam to actually take
over Europe and then the United States
and by that make us can not convert but
submit to Islam not criticize it or they
blow stuff up they thought they'd bring
in some you know new masculine arm that
would make us submit and it got so bad
that even our own intelligence agencies
that
been corrupted said well this is too far
we're not doing it and so America about
four years ago started coming back up
for air and now we're just overthrowing
their whole system there's a huge war
going on it's beautiful
we are kicking their ass on every front
now like I said at the top it's a it's a
it's the dawn of a new age you were
against george w bush clinton
obama all that you are not a Republican
or a Democrat you weren't for you were
against government but now it's a new
day
now the conspiracy theorists like
yourself you're the king of them were
pro-government and the Sheep they're
like out there protesting crime explain
that well I mean look it's not that
trumps perfect he really genuinely is
like going into all these corporate
incentives and one-sided deals there's
no meetings now there's no lobbyists he
banned them all for a lifetime he
literally goes ham with actuaries and
computer programs and goes with super
NSA technology that even had before he
was in and he says because the generals
came to him years ago they said we could
deliver all this to everybody we don't
want to make America poor we don't want
to have big Wars the ones just have
prosperity sir we've got next to free
energy all these technologies cures for
cancer we're ready to release it that's
what he talked about the State of the
Union or his his first inaugural speech
and says it will be the second and he
just really cares about humanity and
he's not a Satanist he doesn't like
raping kids he likes super hot Eastern
European women
he's somebody not out to get humanity
and he's got the intelligence agencies
totally backing to the hill and it's
just a super epic moment to be alive
what's going on so far with Trump hold
on one second
so you what do you think when you you
said earlier in the podcast you don't
think he's perfect right what do you
think he could do different that would
make people accept him well I said last
week he should just about torture he did
it the next day just magically I guess
you came up with this about tortures the
zeitgeist and I'm in the zeitgeist so in
that sight guys you just kind of see
everything right even though you're like
just a normal person you can like look
into any avenue of any
but your your take on it is that it's
good to have him in despite whatever
flaws people may perceive as well he
wants prosperity and he's not a part of
the system that he replaced that's why
they're totally against and he likes
full-grown women
okay I believe that you can only have to
say that anymore no but I'm just I'm
just joking you know most people are
serious most people like they're like
Theresa get out of your backyard and
torture him for a couple weeks yeah
the kidnap they torture they raise and
the emails are like well these are kind
of exhaustive or about to have to retire
them so you need to get in there some of
these are damaged look him up you didn't
believe me no I believed you let's look
I don't know what just breaks their jaws
so do you think from this going after
him oh yeah if he's successful it's an
entire route like a lot of people aren't
just getting indicted right now they're
getting take care of Jebel stop Trump
he's the devil stopping anything we've
got stopping that's what the Vatican
said yeah the Vatican pedophile central
is [ __ ] their pants over Trump the
Vatican is so bizarre yeah can you
imagine Trump going after the Vatican
it's a country crazy about it is he yeah
what this is what Alex I always thought
how weird is it that everybody in the
South Park is making a goddamn episode
about them being pedophiles and yet
nobody's investigating what's going on
here so to me you think you watch
conspiracy of silence that documentary
that never got released about the whole
network then you begin to realize oh
[ __ ] no the reason my opinion is the
reason no one's getting arrested at the
Vatican at a high rate anyways is
because everybody at the top is involved
that's said let me with the good news
I'm not here to kiss to ask the
establishment a lot of Patriots in the
government who have always criticized
ended up being the people that heard me
[ __ ] and you bitching do something
they done something and they're really
trying to reverse this whole thing right
now and there is a full-out war inside
the government of guys that like to eat
steaks drink beer and having women
versus a bunch of pot-bellied pedophiles
whoa Jesus Christ what's really [ __ ]
up is that the people that before the
Sandusky thing came out the people
around it probably heard rumors it was
probably someone to talk someone had
said something but nobody really wanted
to believe it well a minute when it did
happen
well a conspiracy of silence is a
documentary c'mon you seen the never got
released you know they're talking about
the base the headquarters of the the
pedophile Network
it's an international network is in
Omaha Nebraska at Boys Town they they
like taking orphans orphans there's
different levels there's guys we don't
want any trouble they just want one
sentence lead and there's no psychos
that want to go kidnap there's like the
hardcore people and you know what
they're at top officials in in every
aspect of government and celebrity it's
not everybody but it's enough so there's
enough people involved that nobody's
investigating anybody because they're
all involved they all got to keep their
mouths just so crazy that something gets
to the level of the Catholic Church got
to with it myself and Donald Trump yes
sure go fill out to do this
wait a minute before you do it no Trump
basically said we're gonna clean it up
Alex we know all about it Alex we're
gonna stop them and we're gonna do it he
also said Obama's from Kenya well that
was when that's a huge intelligence hop
you want to write that down you don't
know about Reagan about birth
certificate okay now can tell you the
full scoop on that right what do you
think happened there I know exactly what
they told him that Obama was from Kenya
they [ __ ] with him anyway here right
now yes okay I was gonna tell the Trump
story that Trump story
Thank You Eddie story powerful lady
Bravo what do you would oh maybe not
Alex come on okay
if you partner 20 rows I'm gonna [ __ ]
you mention how many years 7 years so
what were you just about to say what was
that what was the issue Jesus Christ do
you remember what the question was Jamie
what Donald Trump told you now that
wasn't in yeah I know you've have to see
what Donald Trump told you who knows it
about I wanted to know about something
else but let's leave [ __ ] but hold on a
second we [ __ ] with my memory what
was it you were just you were just give
up I'm not the only one I should have a
good memory not remember how were too
high this good the Trump's weak Trump
Jamie's gonna figure it out Jamie's
gonna figure it out what is it someone
will tell me Justin yeah someone's gonna
tell him on Twitter and we'll figure
this out Jesus Christ and then all right
this is a problem with being too high
and talking over each other who's about
to tell Trump calls many times a week on
average for a long time 10 hours Joe no
no this should be your longest podcast
we will definitely peter out before then
no no no go forever do it is no one
knows what the [ __ ] we were just talking
about a minute cuz we're blasting it and
you better you better call your
dispensary and get some answer so you
were talking about the Vatican we were
talking about pedophiles in the Catholic
Church certificate I'm not ashamed of
this cuz I got conned well not when I've
been conned which happens you know every
once in a while you know I admit it
later we learned from it cauldron okay
what happened come on we told you Kenya
Kenya what okay Kenya okay everything
I'm gonna say your listeners can write
this down they can search engine
everything I'm gonna say and learn that
see this for themselves cuz okay the
journey with Infowars is it's not that
I'm that smart I'm just like you I'm
having this journey and I'm gonna show
you so this is what happened okay
Obama's running for office and Hillary's
people because I follow the news every
day Hillary's campaign this letter came
out puts out these born in Kenya no my
god screw her I was quietly
really ashamed of this about told
listeners this all just said I was
I wasn't early on Obama supporter in
that I wanted to try to unify people I
didn't like John McCain so I said yeah
he's bad the Democrats are bad but I
hated what had happened so much gonna
fooled my Obama too well I was hopeful
let's get let him talk I mean I wasn't
Obama supporter I didn't attack him you
liked it better than the alternative
yeah I didn't push him for office I was
just like hoping that all his BS was
real okay so and I start hearing there's
these leaks and it was from Hillary and
Google that said Hillary first Pro
generated the whole the whole deal so
I'm sitting there hearing that that he's
born in Kenya something I don't care
that's a bunch of BS and then the
articles start coming out is the right
wing pic so that one does the research
and it's his wife in like 2006 and seven
in speeches going my husband born in
Kenya knows about the immigrants
experience it's video you can pull up
Michelle Obama
oh yeah pull it up and then and then
Harvard Law Review which he headed up
for at least three years he was the
editor he says I was born in Kenya a
little bitty blurb by his picture right
oh yeah says he's worried but he wasn't
more in Kenya what I get for this oh so
that was just like Pizza game oh it's
like I finally learned how that no
double-cross well it's not not in
pedophilia I mean hold on let's here say
which is still plaguing so many of our
communities which you all know a lot of
that is due to homophobia Barack has led
by example when we took our trip to
Africa and visited his home country in
Kenya we took a public HIV test for the
very point of showing folks okay but
that doesn't mean that he was like it
was another club he just found that fast
but there's another where she said
there's the Harvard Law Review what she
edited where he says I was born in Kenya
okay well that would shoot up right
there what she's saying is his homeland
like if you're from Ireland like I want
to go back to Italy or Ireland during
yeah this was the holy land they call it
the homeland let's just going on to
recovery
can you Trump certificate yeah so yeah
Trump got involved in all that so an OLE
bursary we'll go ahead no no so how did
it what
someone like leaked that information to
him to try to make him look foolish
because he chased after it yes so well
we're just researching it's not anybody
from anybody foolish so do you think
they just maybe made it incorrect judge
we found out all about it this is
stunning information so people want to
say he's illegitimate they then look at
him in the Harvard Law Review saying
he's warning can you look at clips they
look at the fact he won't release his
birth certificate he had a name named
Barry satura in Indonesia he had all
these weird cutout names all here like
five aliases Wow
why is any rope then he wrote dreamed
look it up you're a baller
he wrote dreams of my real father right
her dreams my father had reason the real
father was the documentary and in and he
talks about Frank Marshall Davis the
communist famous pornographer that he
spent summers with he looked
side-by-sides the same guy so they were
worried that it was gonna be Frank
Marshall Davis but it actually been his
mom in like a scam making money off she
was CIA bringing back people the US and
sham marriages to have them emigrate it
was basically a cover-up of the fact
that his real father was Frank Marshall
Davis the communist and so that's who
Obama's real dad was and dreams my real
father breaks it all down it's online
it's pretty powerful info so what does
that mean it just is a perfect example
of you're not born in Kenya you're
really born in Hawaii it on the Mew no
main city based island there in Honolulu
to Frank Marshall Davis right
and your grandfather CIA your mother's
CIA that's all been Declassified here
that's cut out because mom was the CIA
oh yeah what was he what did she do for
the CIA she was a sex operative oh yeah
and and and she posed for news photos it
kind of Betty Page style with sex
operatives in photos at Frank Marshall
Davis house and you know this because
you've seen these I've interviewed the
people involved I've read dreams of my
father where he admits I stayed at Frank
Marshall Davis his house he was like my
dad my grandfather had a special
unspoken relationship with him these are
quotes
look up Obama Frank Marshall Davis or
Obama drew thought about what do you
think about the conspiracy
see theory that Obama was like bred by
the CIA the whole way through all the
way truce on the third oh really
when you say CIA that just means like a
marketing project of whoever was in
power at the time four or eight years
whoever's in charge of that whoever
shows interest can go in and then he's
basically be involved in controlling the
levers of the social engineering of the
society hmm so what does that have to do
with Obama growing up did were those
rumors that he was in in a CIA agent in
Pakistan while he was supposed to be in
Colombia exactly he probably spent six
months yeah there's a supposed father
Barack vs Barack the second versus Frank
Marshall Davis huh I think he looks more
like the other Barack okay well look up
look up Frank Marshall Davis is
pornography and I will do no such thing
Obama's mother clearly in the photos
his book dreams of my father admitting
that he stayed with Frank Marshall Davis
hmm okay but listen that's not the issue
so the but I asked you though to get
back to where we started from was why
did Trump chase after that hole he was
born in Kenya [ __ ] for so long because
he knew it was super hot with the public
and he wanted to know the answer to it
as well and didn't like the things Obama
was doing mm-hmm it was a weird thing
right because if you were a guy who was
a white guy and we wanted to prove that
you're born in Austria but you had some
birth certificate that said you were
born in the United States he spoke
perfect English but you got a square jaw
you look like you're from the frozen
north like this mother [ __ ] isn't
freeze from Austria dude I'm telling you
he's from [ __ ] Austria and then
someone like made a big deal out of it
and gave you like a fake birth
certificate and people wouldn't do you'd
never hear racism and then interesting
like you would hear that yeah this guy
might really have been born in other
countries something that yeah it's a
race it'll be instantaneously it gets
connected to racism there's an assumed
racism with almost any color Barack
Obama loved Jimi Hendrix music
celery is long the watchtower is the
best ever it's a pretty goddamn good
song oh yeah all of that so all I'm
telling you is you research Frank
Marshall Davis and Obama I believe it is
it's cracking I'm conclusive it is my
mom and dad are we talking about like
five years ago they thought that's crazy
let us see the film about it they saw it
they were blown away but listen let me
give you the big picture please the
elite admit that they are studying
humanity like they're a breakaway
civilization they believe they're taking
the best ideas of humanity and building
a breakaway civilization of technocracy
so they can transcend us and I want the
public to know the decision has been
made to dumb you down balkanize you turn
you against yourselves have regional
wars play people off against each other
and then basically release bio weapons
that wipe out most the population
okay well the Atlantic transcendent you
know this right here who are the elite
like when you say the elite who are
these people and how do they get
together hold on a second how do they
all agree who votes how do they decide
type a super billionaire characters who
like run and [ __ ] so how do they get
together and all agree on the same thing
they decided agendas that will empower
their individual agendas and they're
pretty much let into those power
structures early on side of they because
they are okay Bilderberg Group this
house the Bilderberg Group love of Rome
Bilderberg Group what's the Club of Rome
Davos Club of Rome is a population
reduction group I mean if you go to
enforce calm right now there's an
article and a video I caught about Oprah
Winfrey I'm not saying some bad person
where she's part of a secret eugenics
group hold on a second stop right there
he said I'm not saying she's a bad
person but she's part of a secret
eugenics crew by like killing weak
people I'm just trying to thin the herd
I'm a really good person though yeah
that's hilarious it's like absolutely so
you can go there it's the truth about
Oprah Winfrey okay and it just deals
with it's in the news soy Oprah Winfrey
and secretly be a face you look so
serious with the toilet you think she's
in secret meetings with like the
Bilderberg Group or something she admits
that okay to her Papa they admit on the
news to reduce population right all
because we leaked it first by play go
ahead but let's play know when someone
like her
your stock hold please when someone like
her says something about reducing the
amount of illegitimate babies born or
the amount of babies that are born
because there's no birth control a lot
of times those kind of statements get
construed into population control she's
in the street and people start saying
she's into population control and that
means she what secret meetings and she's
pushing it and she's taxing jail I'm not
in those secret meetings are you and
those secret meetings I don't you go to
those things that we like to have you
ever been in one of those secret
meetings I did check in the one do you
hear what they said yes did you say say
they want to kill half the people know
what they say that was really like it
wasn't I remember that yeah dude that
was that was a real [ __ ] you know big
[ __ ] Jim Brown type show yeah dude I
mean that is like if you want to go back
to like conspiracy theory fuel like
people that get excited about something
when you find out that there really are
a bunch of global elites to get on this
ranch and they got a [ __ ] giant stone
owl and they burn a bundle of wood and
effigy and they all wear [ __ ] masks
and [ __ ] and then you actually have
video footage of it and this weird sort
of a ceremony they're doing whether it's
satanic or not they're pretending
they're pretending it is whatever
whatever it is it's crazier and I was
like and they hi yeah go into that how
did you sneak into the Bohemian Grove
that was amazing
well people always said it was a seventh
levy and it wasn't quite like that we
have an insider wanted to get me in to
actually see it and most people aren't
bad to go to it but the point is it's
kind of a gateway into all of this it's
amazing so this is you Apple he Mian
Grove and you're and you're on the other
side of liquor looks like a little pond
or something I feel free to play he goes
beyond old care make fire make merriment
with your dust be gone old care it was
so strange it was so bizarre listening
to that guy and the speaker blaring out
across the rock I play it put let's
let's play something that was Walter
Cronkite
something a play for high school it is
it's all play but but religion started
that way as entertainment so what do you
think this is just some really ancient
ritual that they're redoing yeah I
thought it was no big deal till I was in
the crowd of old men they were just
lavishing they were like they loved it
basically ejaculating their parents you
sure are you projecting no no they were
like did ecstasy what is it about people
that love those secret societies like
you remember that JFK speech about
secret societies who will not tolerate
them yeah it's a [ __ ] beautiful
speech Wow because I'll pull it up Jimmy
pull up JFK speech about secret
societies power over others who don't
crave secret essence right they're
looking for that secret place of the
Most High yeah no absolutely that's but
that's just like you were talking about
pedophiles just like you know any other
deviant [ __ ] and or anything yeah I
just want to go eat a big pile of steaks
and drink some beer funny how you say
let's crank this up ladies and gentlemen
the very word secrecy is repugnant in a
free and open society and we are as a
people inherently and historically
opposed to secret societies to secret
oaths and to secret proceedings I'm by
myself put plan put the sunroof you ever
heard the changes he's talking about
secret societies of pertinent facts far
outweighed the dangers which are cited
to justify it even today there is little
value in opposing the threat of a closed
society by imitating its arbitrary
restrictions even today there is little
value in insuring the survival of our
nation if our traditions do not survive
with it and there is very grave danger
that an announced need for increased
security will be seized upon by those
anxious to expand its meaning to the
very limits of officials
censorship and concealment that I do not
intend to permit to the extent that it's
in my control
and no official of my administration
whether his rank is high or low civilian
or military the like should interpret my
words here tonight as an excuse to sense
of the news right to stifle dissent they
knew it to cover up our mistakes or to
withhold from the press and the public
the facts they deserve to know well we
are opposed around the world here this
by a monolithic and ruthless conspiracy
that relies primarily on covet means for
expanding its sphere of influence on
infiltration instead of invasion on
subversion instead of Elections on
intimidation instead of free choice on
guerrillas by night instead of armies by
day it is a system which has conscripted
vast human and material resources into
the building of a tightly knit highly
efficient machine that combines military
diplomatic intelligence economic science
chuggabug common political operations
it's preparations are concealed not
published its mistakes are buried not
headlined
it's dissenters are silenced not praised
no expenditure is questioned no rumor is
printed no secret is revealed no
president should fear public scrutiny of
his program for from that scrutiny comes
understanding and from that
understanding comes support or
opposition and both are necessary I am
NOT asking your newspapers to support an
administration but I am asking your help
in the tremendous task of informing and
alerting the American people for I have
complete confidence we're cool until
then that's a that's such a crazy speech
because it's him talking about the
structures that were already in place
and about the dangers withholding
information for people and him being
forthright as a presen
in a way that we've never heard before
since like he's literally talking until
Trump Trump Trump spinning like that now
what a Trump tell you well let's just be
clear he's talking about our own
military industrial complex that
Eisenhower just warned about his
outgoing predecessor he's talking about
the Soviets there at the same time he
was a really smart cookie
the Eisenhower warning is one of the
creepiest things in human history yeah
about that sounded like he was talking
about communists yeah pull up Eisenhower
warns of the military-industrial complex
he did it but just Boop there's a clip
that just has that segment of it we show
for ya there was a lot he says there is
a scientific technocratic elite that is
in control of all information about to
shut it down to the public and then they
will control the military so beware the
military ones in the military was bad
right he said these two
military-industrial hew Genesis we're
about to get control over the scientific
people I told you about see if you can
find where it goes zip Jamie this is the
address right here we now stand ten
years past the midpoint of a century
that has witnessed four major wars among
great nations
[Music]
Joe's right type in Eisenhower
military-industrial complex speech yeah
he's gonna say it in here somewhere but
it's a three-minute speech hey Alex it
seems like Trump you know everybody a
lot of smart people in different points
of their life they begin to realize how
much how many lies they've been told
they begin to wake up they're not
totally woke up but they begin to wake
up and then they find out about 9/11 but
they don't believe all this other [ __ ]
and then they find out about this but
they don't believe in all that other
[ __ ] then they find about that and then
at the very high levels like the dudes
there's like yeah all this [ __ ] is true
if you could follow the money it's
probably true you might be wrong one or
two or three times but generally we're
dealing with a totally crooked situation
that's what are they doing they're not
stealing money from corporations you
steal money from a corporation and gonna
come after you and kill you with what
they're doing is it's the mastery of
stealing tax money that's what this is
all about it's just stealing nobody cuz
nobody's gonna go after you steal tax
money you get all these programs in
these bills pass let's play this good
Jim these military contractors the
taxpayers are paying for all this so is
the very structure of our society in the
council's of government from us we must
guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military-industrial
complex the potential for the disastrous
rise of misplaced power exists and will
persist we must never let the weight of
this combination endanger our liberties
or democratic processes Jesus Christ
they left that out like it was so tight
as you think about this back in the
early days of radio in the early days of
moving pictures only only the elite had
access to this technology moving
pictures radio right from the get-go
right from Dave
right from day one it wasn't like your
average guy was trying to help humanity
the guys who had this technology we're
like damn they believe whatever the [ __ ]
we say back in the day you'd listen to
the radio those news reports or when the
movie pictures were reefer madness
yes that's what I'm talking about right
when they hit go TV movies radio all of
it was propaganda let me tell you what
happened never left Alex Jones as aliens
involved in this story no talk about
propaganda new Eisenhower had LL
Leominster come to him who that was the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs ll Linden
sirs that is now just Google operation
Northwoods oh I know about that sure so
they came to him and they said we're
gonna launch terror attacks in America
and start a war with the Soviets it's
like whoa I know they're evil but we're
not gonna do that so he fired him then
JFK comes in the same guys try to make
him do it
he refuses so they kill him well they
wanted to have drone jetliners and blow
them up and blame it on the Cubans 9/11
they wanted to arm Cuban friendlies and
attack Guantanamo Bay they had a bunch
of really crazy [ __ ] planned when you
realize what our operation Northwoods
was and you realize that this was signed
by the Joint Chiefs of Staff it scares
the [ __ ] out of you talking here we're
talking here doesn't that scare the [ __ ]
out of you yeah blow your mind
that there's still today it's 2007 -
doesn't it blow your mind that people
still think that 9/11 happened the way
it will get to that operation Northridge
is a hundred percent crazy back to that
Declassified 2000 well when people
realize that that was a real document
the US government plan to start war with
Russia and kill p-play blow up movie
theaters attack US military bases kill
Americans in Capitol Hill American
military people hijacked jets crash him
have CIA get on board so fake plane
lands or the real plane lands a fake
plane attacks was it was 9/11 it's just
bananas that someone would actually sit
down and weigh it wasn't leaked by
Patriots six months before 9/11 trying
to stop it and that's not saying Islamic
terrorism real it's not saying Bushman
did it some super dark state group which
Congress now has the 28 pages vindicate
9/11 truthers that Saudi Arabia with
people that they had gotten to convert
to Islam and paid off with her trillions
they got trillions had joined them in
some larger plan to blame Iraq in other
countries that were non radical so Saudi
Arabia could take them over who who put
together 9/11 Saudi Arabia the Muslims I
know some of anybody so they want to
invade these other countries that had
happened in the US I mean the US wasn't
involved
of course what are you saying who was
involved who were the key players in
9/11 it's totally compartmentalized so
you run a drill of the World Trade
Center and the Pentagon being attacked
on that day so the planes are told
flying around oh that was a drill that
was supposed to be run that day it all
came out a drill that was about a false
flag site it seems like okay we're gonna
do a false flag we need to set up a
drill they need a drill going on clear
it's 99.9% of the government wasn't
involved because of computers it was a
test they get his stuff a hundred times
worse now no one will know because it's
all remote-activated the Jets by then
we're all remote control every jet for
25 years the big new ones has control
control it's all it's all it's crazy man
there's jets now are unmanned absolutely
well no they're manned it's just
thinking to go on autopilot the drone
jetliners when they were gonna blow up
that jetliner and blame it on the Cubans
that wasn't gonna be a jetliner filled
with people it's gonna be a drone so
they had the capability in 1962 of doing
that which is how did robert f kennedy
or JFK's older brother who was Joe
Kennedy jr. died he was flying a fighter
plane remote-controlling to b-17 blow
with explosives as drones to crash into
Germany they had drums in World War two
Jesus Christ
they had drones in World War two what
were they powered by how did Joe Kennedy
jr. die
he does a great mission over Germany it
does seem like a father know the Joe
Kennedy jr. oh the crazy thing about the
Kennedy's is is you know if you're a lot
of times you see criminals come from
like a good family and then you see
Robert Kennedy and John F Kennedy they
come from gangster his dad as a gangster
straight-up
mafia and then he has two kids they
thought they had him under control
because he's from a Mafia family John a
here's the here's the guy's name Joe
Kennedy isn't that weird cuz it's like
you're the opposite of your parents like
you want to go against your parents so
Robert Kennedy and John F Kennedy they
went against that [ __ ] that that's the
only reason they were in the mob
supported Bob stole Illinois form the
mom supported John F Kennedy he was
hanging out with Frank Sinatra then all
of a sudden he flipped and you know what
he stopped hanging out with Frank
Sinatra he started changing his ways
something flipped did they did he have a
kid that died or something like that is
that that may something made him flip I
thought I spread something it could be
total [ __ ] but it could be that he
had a son that died that made him that
could make you think totally different
for sure when your kid dies you're like
[ __ ] this I'm going with Eddie Bravo my
soul right yeah you're like [ __ ] this
what could be worse what could my son
already died I'm coming after you yeah
like a [ __ ] Apache savage with
nothing to lose
Joe so Joe Kennedy jr. was killed in
action while serving as a land-based
patrol bomber pilot in World War two and
would posthumously awarded the Navy
Cross Alex Jones thrown down dude you're
[ __ ] you're on fire this was almost
three hours there's people out there
just laying it down
you're laying it down like game a
[ __ ] Thrones on like you're yes
you are all I know is there's people in
the government that want to empower
people and they're trying to get a job
and I'm not anti-government I want to
have a good constitutional government
and the truth is
I couldn't believe it one in my PD
contacts and we have a Secret Service
the Secret Service came to me when I was
the aren't see sounds like the number
one passes nobody had read passes I'd go
behind the scenes nobody stopped me but
back in the back deal
The Secret Service thing in there Cisco
hey Alex come here I want to tell you
something about Hillary give us a
contact number well the next month we're
gonna contact you about a month later
I'll get a contact they go can you come
to it as nothing's digital you come down
at me at this place
so I go down and meet or meet one of my
other people as well cuz where they
worked was like they're hitting both
sides of our operation and they said to
me Hillary has seizures like every 30
minutes
she's got an ambulance it's blacks he
falls down all the time just have your
people at her events you'll see her
falling down she's covering it up well
sure enough a month I doubts that on air
a month later she falls down in front of
the cameras we had footage week before
in Cleveland again same place she was
back to oh it was a key battleground and
she she was like for an hour in this
emergency tent with that with ambulances
and stretchers so I'm telling you I mean
I've got real sources that really care
about what's happening in this country
and everything he told me was dead-on
you know what's scary about my
government leaks let's go go back so you
bring your honor the the Hillary thing
was very bizarre because nobody was
supposed to mention it like you weren't
supposed to mention that she was falling
down they said oh she had pneumonia let
me tell you something I've had pneumonia
you know what I haven't done I haven't
ever walked and just falling down while
I'm walking really free of the
background that a comment on this is key
it's known that in 2012 she fell on her
head and she got a severe concussion was
researching for my sources but yeah
she's in the hospital for a year then
she yeah she was [ __ ] up for six whole
months according to Clinton so she's
like hell we don't know where she is and
then meanwhile I'm told hey she's
falling down all the time she looks like
hell on TV and then Secret Service says
look you've got the people get up off
your ass and follow her so we follow her
in like five cities we didn't catch it
we were in New York they sneak her out
she falls down having epilepsy every 15
20 minutes 30 minutes the point is is my
Intel was good they gave us good info so
what are the elite things
they're gonna put somebody in with
epilepsy that's home Sam but do you
think that it was just that their idea
was cheating hold it together just
anything rather than as soon as they if
they just want her to get her through
get all those girls like oh my god
everything's great and then they pass
all these [ __ ] bills and it was
oh it seemed to me that when all this
was happening that people so desperately
wanted to not look at it because the
alternative was Trump it wasn't that
they were taking an objective look at
and go wow maybe she shouldn't be
blacking out and then you consider that
massive head injury that she had in 2012
which is real it's a fact yeah I don't
like it when you bring that up though
because they think if you bring that up
you're going to change people's opinion
and you're gonna help Trump win can I
just pick two minutes to talk to your
audience what switch cameras about Trump
that one Justin I don't claim to have
all the answers and I'm not here to
boost your Trump because I'm tied to his
wagon if I attacked Trump I'd make more
money this isn't about money it's about
the truth Trump really is trying to cut
taxes and make people successful and
wealthy he really does care about the
average person the elite upset of a plan
to enslave people to make folks poor and
all I'm asking you to do is get past
thinking that you're part of the
establishment or you're smart because
you're anti Trump I'm asking you to
actually look at what's really being
going on and understand that Democrats
Republicans come and go some are good
some are bad the whole power structure
has been against Trump for a very
serious reason Trump is coming after
them and really is attempting to bring
down this whole global system and that's
why all hell's breaking loose so I just
want your viewers and listeners to know
I'm not some political hack like you
said earlier I used to be against bush
I wish Obama would have been real the
point is they got to Obama would trump
he doesn't give a damn they admit their
offering and money everything he doesn't
listen so you think what Trump could
excuse me what Obama could have been is
who he was when he was running for
office that he was this radical element
of change hope and change he wanted to
close down Guantanamo Bay he's wanted to
do all these things they're all that
posters in the back during his
administration the DEA decided to not
take marijuana off the schedule one
everybody knows it's not scheduled it
was the cover schedule one mean
no medical use he's not it means that's
what it means to be scheduled one that
it's crazy that marijuana is Schedule
one when it's the most useful out of all
the different very smart you are Joe you
smoke marijuana quite a bit you're still
smoking it's definitely not bad for just
smelling it I can't even figure I know
you can't listen let's get serious
let's look I'm telling you it's Trump
about what are those conversations about
let the people know I mean Trump really
wants to make poor people rich he really
wants to defeat collectivism
collectivism he hates all the bashing
the family and what's collected it's all
the New World Order collectivism is this
thing like you're not an individual you
like part of a group and Trump can't
stand that he can't stand seeing as a
businessman business deals where China
has like 35% currency tariffs on us
there's no way you can even compete and
they're shutting off our power plants
with regulations but not tears why do we
do that then what is the reason why
because our elites under a quite frankly
under under under Kissinger and and and
and of course you know the president who
was in that administration Nixon they
made a one-sided deal for elites to go
make deals with China and their billion
plus slaves I don't say that kind of
sending Li they're like slaves to
leverage out to less the whole world's
industry and Trump doesn't like those
one-sided deals and he's saying listen
we're not gonna impoverished America
we're gonna empower America and we're
gonna actually use American power to
promote freedom worldwide so let me get
this straight for guys like me that it
all Trump's does a little on promises
well like so what you're saying is in
layman's terms the the elite the the
people in power the people that have the
green light power to sign these treaties
they were maybe offered a couple mil
here a couple mil there and from assign
this to sell the country out so that
they could make 10 mil here five mil
their bills anything like that the u.s.
got colonized by corporate takeover
artists and Trump at the end said fu so
we're gonna take their whole global
system they built for nothing take it
away from them and have the true new
American millennium not the new century
you list
into his I don't know we got the title
if you want to play his 18 minute share
to the Union we could start or not sales
will Fidel his his his his global
inauguration speech he lays the whole
beautiful [ __ ] out and so if anybody
ever wanted to actually have somebody
trying to make them great and wealthy
and powerful its Donald J Trump that's
why the whole elite the whole power
structure Hollywood all the pedophiles
every damn demon every pot-bellied one
inched [ __ ] you know they are all
against Trump because he is pro human
and he wants to dominate all these
people it is an act of an alpha male he
wants and it fits of the ego every now
and then every now and then yeah well he
helped him run for office it he talks to
you and and he calls you right I mean
you know people think people they don't
know Alex Jones they believe the
mainstream media when they try to
crucify them and say he's a [ __ ] quack
and he's well Alex what you need
honestly is someone to temper you you
you need me right next to you all the
time to balance this is you being right
there that you're like the [ __ ] you
need to calm them down you got a bio
suit on and you got a [ __ ] ray gun
you're like okay we need this alien to
benefit humanity but I gotta put this
goddamn bio suit on cuz he's going crazy
just got a just kind of to steer him
occasionally he just gives it on you get
on rants and you'll get you couldn't
connect four or five different non
related subjects but that's that's
that's beautiful go right after rent
after rent after rent with no
teleprompters only a guy that could do
I'm actually very nice that that Joe has
finished all my sentences and knows more
than I do and it's it's over there
acting like he doesn't know all this
know no more than you do more than
every document every secret program menu
all about it you know was a bullshitting
let's say the whole time you've been
[ __ ] you are Billy listen I'm
Microsoft on cigarette about Billy he's
a very common I'm microscopic bacterial
penis atomic split the goddamn critical
mass compared to Joe Rogan I'm nothing
I'm nothing and I've talked so much [ __ ]
about conspiracy theories that I feel
like I need to shut the [ __ ] up because
I don't I don't want any questions of
the yours
it's questioning on your own the mystery
and not just receiving the priest class
stuff yes I'm not trying to I walked
away from my podcast no but I thought
nobody was listening but now people want
me to go back I thought nobody but
listen I don't want to be a conspiracy
guy like you I don't want to be that but
I listen to you and you are my canary in
the goddamn coma as long as you're alive
I feel like I'm okay to say [ __ ] but
I'll tell you this every time I come to
do the fight companion Joe Joe Rogan
experience I swear to God I tell myself
this something in me wants to help
people for some reason and a lot of
times my enemies like [ __ ] damn make a
[ __ ] you know to me [ __ ] them and I'm
like damn if I just walk away cuz i I'm
compelled but I'm not trying to make
money off conspiracy theories I have a
conspiracy theory podcast right now and
it would be okay I'm not even trying to
do that I don't want to do that okay I
don't want to be that guy I don't wanna
be you but something inside me when the
[ __ ] mics there and someone's
question I'm like I got a son and I want
to make sure did I [ __ ] do everything
I can for him because I don't want him I
don't want to leave him with some [ __ ]
that I could have changed so inside of
me I'm like on the fence
all the time careful careful when you're
overzealous yeah because if you're
overzealous then you actually turn
people the wrong way
they look at any conspiracies is being
preposterous even the ones that are real
like Sandusky like the Catholic Church
like so many other ones before there's a
ton of them like Hastert who was the
Speaker of the [ __ ] house pedophile
there's been a lot of Frank so it's
really great our set but hold on a
second hold on a second Eddie it's
really critical whenever you're
discussing any of these things you get
all the [ __ ] ducks in order before
you pick a side it's super important
because any time you make some crazy
claim and it's connected to a conspiracy
theory and it proves to be wrong it
[ __ ] with all the ones that are not
people they're saying that it's like
their eye hurts me they're that dumb
that they don't know my own it's a joke
it's a joke meme man it's on reddit [ __ ]
they're having fun Mellisa getting you
know someone were serious yeah but
they're having no they're not Alex let
me ask you something really quick is
very important let me ask the super
important like I was I was trying to say
this earlier but we had to go back and
finish something out but this is very
important I I teach two Jitsu I got
students all over the world I got
schools all over the world I all my
students a what start tool
wake up you know that's like a metaphor
a conspiracy theory much like at
different times some are just into me
for jujitsu but they believe the CNN
side a hundred percent it takes in three
years and they're like oh [ __ ] they
start smoking weed and damn they're all
all over the conspiracy side everybody
awakens at a different point no matter
how smart they are you didn't even get
your masters your PhD you could be all
I'm a scientist or whatever but you're
working for the government and you ain't
thinking about [ __ ] but listen listen do
you think Donald do you think Donald
Trump is in the middle of an awakening
he's like is he in the middle of an
awakening yes because he could easily
been a billionaire
two more two years ago who bought all
the mainstream [ __ ] but he was a
billionaire he didn't give a [ __ ] about
the mainstream
he's cutting D
but now at a certain point no matter
where you are no matter how smart you
are you awaken a little little by living
from Donald Trump knows which way the
winds going and as Julius Caesar in in
the famous play by William Shakespeare
of Julius Caesar there's a tide in the
affairs of men which taken at the flood
leads on to fortune or as Mark Twain
said in the beginning of Patriots the
scarce man hated and feared and scorned
for the time when it's cause exceeds it
costs nothing to join a patriot so
here's what's happening right now
there's a major shift happening and
Trump really wants to empower the people
globalism is anti-human and so all I'm
trying to get at is is that some really
big things are happening in this world
and people watching shouldn't be
conservative or liberal
can you stop try stopping for a moment
when you say globalism what do you mean
by that please define that globalism is
like neo colonialism but it's corporate
colonialism over humans individuals
government states old world new world
it's worldwide colonialism is it
Rothschild roots potentially its
monopoly populations and create
centralized systems of monopolies in
controlling was - in innovation it was
to end upward mobility why do is it is
also globalism as corporate world
government why do they want to stop
innovation because they see it I was at
Burbank they see it as what they call
disruptive technology and humanity is so
powerful you've already got a monopoly
so is this a recent consideration after
the Internet has ended you know global
is bigger than that but yes okay you're
part of that's true since they've
already got control they want
competition to end they're in control
they don't want challengers they've
seized control the human psyche human
development to the Stars they've got it
all they think they're getting rid of
humanity humming gods whatever
dimensions their tune into told them
that so they want debates to end right
and they want authoritarianism
they want to what what happened there
and how is Donald Trump gonna stop this
a bolt came off the you going crazy you
see it as making both come off the car
then how are you hoping it happen
Alex how do you hoping that what drugs
have to do with blocking chances are
energy siphons their vampiric actions
course so if he actually cuts taxes to
poor people middle class and gets rid of
tax incentives for really rich he's not
coming after the rich but from a
conservative perspective so the
Republicans are cheering him this oh is
that what he wants to do he wants to cut
taxes for everybody except the rich he's
gonna increase him really oh yeah that
seems like the opposite of what a rich
guy would do right but he understands
like Henry Ford did you got to sell a
car where people can afford to buy it
mm-hmm you got to pay your employees
with a can buy it he wants real
prosperity he doesn't this is nothing
get off in his in his limousine driving
by burn out old towns does this been
announced this tax plan yeah so Jamie
see if we could pull up what it says
that's fascinating I wonder if that'll
change people's opinions if that really
does happen if people can save a
significant amount of money in taxes the
problem the globalist admit they want a
global consolidation they want a global
downturn to break everybody's will and
they shift all the new taxes and
regulations and so Trump is racing
remember they had for eight years zero
percent Interest mmm but it was only the
big banks Trump said we're gonna keep
zero percentage for one year
you know he's against it but for poor
people to get zero percent interest who
cares is all Fiat anyways the banks lose
the money it's all just write-offs
they're killing it all now and raising
raising taxes Trump tax reform that will
make America great again the goals of
Donald Trump number one tax relief for
middle-class America in order to achieve
the American dream let people keep more
money in their pockets and increase the
after-tax waze's number two simplify the
tax code to reduce headaches Americans
face in preparing their taxes and let
everyone keep more of their money so
he's a man he's already implemented it
though that's in 14 we're twelve days in
we've already got he's doing it so if
you're single and you earn less than
$25,000 or married and jointly earn less
than $50,000 you will not owe any income
tax [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] in the taxes all
that removes nearly seventy five million
households over fifty percent of the
income tax rolls they get a new one-page
form to send to the IRS
I win those who would otherwise Oh how
crazy is that they get to save a new
one-page form to send to the IRS saying
I win this those who would otherwise Oh
income tax will save an average of
nearly $1,000 each yeah it's not that
baby if you're the lowest bracket that
pays taxes and you basically don't pay
taxes you know won't people provable in
taxes are for rich people you're rich
you pay big tips you get it like these
people need money look at that look at
this statement no business of any size
from a fortune 500 to a mom-and-pop shop
to a freelancer living job to job will
pay more than 15% of their business
income in taxes Esther's plan this lower
rate makes corporate investments
inversions unnecessary by making
America's tax rate one of the best in
the world yeah holy [ __ ] yeah we have
all the highest rates so nobody wants to
be here
no family will have to pay the death tax
holy [ __ ] you know about this yeah
that's giant that's right Trump is for
real right oh he's totally you earned
and save that money for your family and
not the government you pay taxes on it
when you earned it that is so beautiful
rich is that is a beautiful tax plan
that death tax is disgusting so I give
you left money for your kid they would
take half your money they take a lot of
summonsed um giant chunk of it and he's
saying that's not gonna happen anymore
that alone that's a beautiful thing
that's a very good thing Trump is
painted land and they're like 70 of them
and like they're like pushing by
families with kids like okay Jake hey
like yelling at families just don't lean
forward they like literally push back
like Hispanic families and black people
screaming KKK and I looked at him on
tape they're just going like what it
feels good for people to have a clear
enemy and if they can justify in their
mind you know white supremacists or
anybody on the alt-right is a racist
dirty trump's KKK
he's a rapist yeah well there's also a
bunch of people that are looking for
some sort of solidarity maybe they were
maybe they thought that Hillary was a
better choice and maybe they got excited
that they could get together and join up
and walk the streets anytime you can get
people to get together for a common good
in their mind at least and no one gets
arrested that's a good thing it's like
traffic for a lot of people made it
annoying yeah what would you do if like
almost half the time you love to eat her
in a grocery store someone's going to
slap you in the back you tell me that it
happens to you right well I wonder where
it's like there interdimensionally
connected like why is it always booth
you're a loser slap you in the face of
the back of the head it's like you just
invited a door for people going who
you're a loser and then try to slap you
in the back of the head it's gonna
happen now you started a human meme now
the carrot the point is how are they so
synced oh here's the deal well you have
women going Allah Akbar
I love God they sink weather media
synced by the media and I'm out there
peacefully videotaping them the Saturday
after Trump's inaugurated in DC before I
leave and they're like f you white male
they're all white women Fu jihad and
they put hats on
they put burkas screaming I'm gonna join
jihad you'll never stop me I'm like I'm
gonna cut your genitals off and put you
on the slave block I don't get where
I've never done anything to women and
all these weird ass women include the DC
police we're all any people attack us
they were wearing like these pink hats
and then they've got attacked phrasing
oh yeah almost saying that you were
drunk that's not true right absolutely
not I didn't think so
no no the truth is Alex Jones kicked out
of inauguration oh yeah they have people
blocking the entrances cuz they're all
fenced off you can get in yeah was the
whole thing is it's it's very the whole
movement is very aggressive
you know it's like a response to what
they think is a
recive you know your all of their slick
asking questions misogyny have heard
let's be serious okay what is your real
world view on the nature of
consciousness on this planet an
intergalactic space I've been have been
a really honest today okay a lot of true
answers so metaphysically what is the
secret of the universe this is what I
think there was a little organism that
was just recently discussed I tweeted it
I think yesterday and they think it was
one of the very first organisms that was
the precursor to what we eventually
became and then all biological life all
like living walking things came out of
this one multi-celled organism right
then yeah some one thing I think as that
happened whatever hundreds of millions
of years ago I don't know what the
number is but whatever however long
billions of years that happened to go if
we keep going in that same direction
whatever we are now it's gonna be
totally unrecognizable just a few
hundred years from now or a few thousand
years from now or if we just do it
biologically a million years from now
but I think that if human beings managed
to stay alive for a long period of time
and not blow each other up we're on the
cusp of figuring out how to manipulate
our very beings like to the point where
we're not going to be people anymore
it's just gonna change that's it yeah
humanity is at the crossroads and that's
my message today the elite have decided
they think the course of our evolution
I'm here to say shouldn't we decide it
and have a debate about it well I don't
know is a great place for that people
have this insatiable need for innovation
that fascinated by it they want the
newest phone even though their phone
works perfect
they just want it they have this desire
it's a weird thing it's just like we
were talking about like these these
things aren't designed to make you
addicted to him you're just addicted to
when they're designed well there's a
weird sort of connection that we have to
this technology and I think it's because
of what Marshall before I think it's
because of what Marshall McLuhan said
the human beings are the sex organs in
the machine world I really think that's
what they're doing I think all of this
integration and all this innovation of
all this none of the primer prevailing
dis compelling focus on technology is
because evolutionarily that's where our
biology goes it goes to technology
because
can manipulate it at a far faster rate
evolution and in what you're saying
bottle mechanically no genetically
through round cells not square silicon
we do it more beautifully and strongly I
agree with what you're saying overall I
don't think it's an either/or
it shouldn't just expand Alex I don't
think it's you just accept it they're
gonna be able to do [ __ ] in both ways
it's gonna be screaming hundred years no
public needs to know this
yes I think you have a larger debate
about well they did they are learning
about it it's just something that you
have to seek out and it's really all the
informations control I don't know about
that the information about is it about
innovation and letting a lot of you were
it's constant study if you were Tony
[ __ ] Montana running the planet would
you let that [ __ ] out or would you keep
it for you but Eddie there's not Tony
Montana is not running science the thing
is these scientists are almost all
involved in universities and different
studies they're working on the PhDs are
trying to make a name for themselves
they're exploring all these different
possibilities and then big companies
that can profit off of it in billions of
billions of dollars like Sony or Apple
or anything other companies and scoop
these people up in there but hold on a
second their thing is to innovate and
make money that's what they're there for
that's what they're doing the drives the
envelope and technology they're not Tony
Montana do you understand this you're
talking about two different things some
utopia no I'm talking about trying to to
benefit I'm talking about what Intel who
makes iPhones doesn't matter we're
having a real discussion about the
future of the technological system of
humanity right they don't want that
discussion so this thing's that whether
it's it's Joe or Alex Jones or any Bravo
we're all having on Joe Rogan experience
a discussion the elite are having right
now in Hawaii right now with Zuckerberg
I know for a fact the lease term eaten
with Zuckerberg and Kauai Facebook to
use about Kauai
but the whole point is they're having
this meeting Facebook now we should
discuss what's happening it's Facebook
part of the Illuminati now you know
[ __ ] in the woods part of it come on our
joint now you know I I know you do I
know you folks off I know you do hey the
big issues of the world is you never
asking about Ronald Reagan I want to
know about aliens but I keep coming back
to that because I want to know what do
they know about aliens well you want to
what are they real okay I'll tell you
right now and what I say is not
political and it's not from my
particularly effective focus from the
known knowledge in the universe okay we
live in a third dimensional plane we can
see the planets the galaxies the suns
hundreds of billions of galaxies
photographed universes we live in an
amazing space-time continuum the elites
believe that it's not in the third
dimension that we're mainly receiving
transmissions ships don't arrive from
alphas and thérèse or GD prime for
wherever they're coming from or Beall
G's they come here they're
interdimensional gates that are much
closer through fold space and so we have
to discuss the different influences
there in the universe and on fact that
we have free will and we decide what we
want I don't believe in any of this I'm
simply telling you what the elites
believe so they believe that there's
another dimension and these beings are
fundamentally need baby blood baby tuned
in we tell you we're really powerful the
socket we're made the image of our
Creator our brain is able to tune into
the lowest dimension the highest have
mentioned humans are basically really
powerful creatures that can live right
close to Suns they're highly radioactive
nothing else can live it's close with
very short lives because we're like a
hive organism that actually lives second
to second in the space-time Continuum's
is like a hundred years it's a second
and we transmit our data up to be able
to live next to like these stargate jump
gates that are that our sons so because
we live so close to these sons we only
have like milliseconds to be alive so
we're actually a hive organism
it keeps transmitting up to the next
species in our in our in a hierarchical
system and then down below us so we're
alive right now in this continuum and
we're trying to progress and make things
better and the elites are trying to make
sure that we don't dial into that
incredible knowledge we've got as a
species it basically dies the species so
they're not competitors on the next
level as the Bible says of the
interventional plane but you don't
believe that you're just saying that's
what they believe
oh yes exactly what do you believe no I
mean I believe in research do you think
that I believe in research - do you
think that there is something from other
dimensions that can access us this this
we are other dimensions the third size
is only one limited plane in a larger
space believes we're a part of that
spectrum well let's just say we're not
in Kansas anymore Alex have you ever
done DMT no do you want to I don't need
to good every night I go to sleep I
believe that he's on it's like he's on
natural DMT I'm definitely on something
man for sure yeah I got a question for
you
you know how this is this is kind of off
the cuff a little bit but off the track
off the beaten path but you know how the
CIA has always been involved in
Hollywood and making movies and you know
like zero dark thirty and you know all
these movies that are clearly propaganda
movies you know most like even movies
you think they weren't propaganda but
they are they're like the superhero
movies how there's just all the plots
and the evil oh they're gonna build a
bomb and all that is it it's they're
whistleblowers within Hollywood that are
making movies just like like in Brazil
it was out martial arts were outlawed so
the people the people that were about
the truth they were like doing dance but
they were disguising them our clearance
is their film eight are their filmmakers
like that out there that are trying to
help humanity with the basis of their
films also Hollywood's like anything
else there's good people and bad people
I don't think Hollywood overall is bad
which movies are the good ones
tell me cuz I watch I like it Star Wars
I'm like is this the bad one that's
propagandizing
the Meryl Streep movies are good ones
good ones Meryl Streep which ones are
the ones I should go no no way what
about like when hangover one comes out
let me tell you hangover God I'm CIA is
only the name of like one part of the
shadow government which is only like the
intellectuals of America so those people
are on Trump's side now yeah and that's
the first time ever well the CIA has
never been perfect his head so they must
have been with Bush right because Bush
used to be the presidency Bush Senior
yeah George Herbert Walker yeah so he
was head of the CIA here's the deal
right the CIA was set up supposedly to
defend the Republic and do all this
stuff it got hijacked by multinational
interests it's been retaken and they're
cleaning the CIA out right now are you
serious that's [ __ ] breaking goddamn
news Infowars the CEOs oh my god that's
are you kidding me why isn't that the
headline news on Infowars right now you
know the rock t-shirt a lot of folks did
really really crazy things for the CIA
that's a mystery the CIA does like half
of fighting and they were all pissed off
and they were portrayed by infiltrators
inside the CIA and really by stuff that
went on but right now there is a counter
kid within the CIA cleaning them out
well they're definitely trying Jesus
Christ yeah I like what I'm hearing well
see what happens but are you are you
happy about the future let's just can if
what I'm succeeds with in three years
you're gonna hear major cancer cures
announced you're gonna hear our new
energy systems announce your new
companies announced they've suppressed
all this stuff and Trump what and good
people want to empower humanity they
believe in the species and the planet
and big stuffs but you know how goddamn
crazy it would be if Trump became a hero
but do you know how crazy the the
country accepted them if they figured
this out after if this is all true this
all comes true exactly as you're saying
which I really have no idea if you're
right
you know what you could play right now
how about that Bill Clinton clip that
you played
what he's talking about vetting
immigrants like more hardcore than try
how do you pull that out of jail Clinton
and Bill Clinton and Hillary promote
wall and the walls that I don't halfway
around disagree with him on the wall cuz
people do a ladder over it's about a
physical it's like we're country we're
allowed to have this Mexico has one
Canada has one can't why can't we the
big thing is just deport people that are
on welfare
we need people from Mexico and Russia
and Japan and we just deport people that
are on welfare it's only deport the
poorest ones the ones that say if you
won't do anything and you're come here
yeah well okay so when they come over
here you're saying give them a chance
but then once if they try to stay on
welfare there's more [ __ ] or not sounds
good this is in nineteen ninety five but
in every place in this country are
rightly disturbed by the large numbers
of illegal aliens entering our country
the jobs they hold might otherwise be
held by citizens or legal immigrants the
public service they use imposed burdens
on our taxpayers that's why our
administration has moved aggressively to
secure our borders more by hiring a
record number of new border guards by
deporting twice as many criminal aliens
as ever before by cracking down on
illegal hiring by borrowing welfare
benefits to illegal aliens alright I
will present to you we will try to do
more to speed the deportation of illegal
aliens who are arrested for crimes to
better identify illegal aliens in the
work face as recommended by the
Commission headed by former
congresswoman Barbara Jordan we are a
nation of immigrants but we are also a
nation of laws it is wrong and
ultimately self-defeating for a nation
of immigrants to permit the kind of
abuse of our immigration laws we have
seen in recent years
and we must do more to stop
if that doesn't vindicate [ __ ] Trump
on all that offense [ __ ] also makes you
realize bad [ __ ] Bill Clinton
was his Trump making speech like that
if you're some chick out there marching
talking about the wall and you just
heard that you don't realize I'm giving
you a chance admit you were Punk'd it's
okay
everybody gets powerful for parts but
from this point on shut the [ __ ] up
about it that's not okay let's it's five
we got it we did a good job one more eye
you know me I'm [ __ ] fascinated with
the conspiracy they're just like you
every night dudes are watching fights
and boxing I'm listening to conspiracies
there's every [ __ ] night when I go to
bed
I listen to Alex Jones every day every
day okay the one thing that gets that I
don't get I get the establishment I get
the Illuminati I get all that [ __ ] but
then there's Ronald Reagan every now and
then you have dr. Steve pathetic on your
show and he's talking about some serious
conspiracy theories all this [ __ ] is
confirming everything he's deep in the
CIA confirming [ __ ] but then when they
talk about Ronald Reagan they talk about
like he was the last great president and
I thought that actor the guy wasn't he
an FBI informant
isn't he show goddamn establishment
Ronald Reagan I don't get that explain
Ronald Reagan I mean George senior was
the vice president director of the CIA
he just seems like a joke shut this off
but this is once in life okay explain
Ronald the transmission oh no explain
Ronald Reagan go ahead we're just joking
around punching earlier no no it's okay
but his question he wants to know about
Ronald Reagan I could trust the movies
Ronald Reagan we're not in some love
fest with Reagan but after all the Obama
globalization it's like a nostalgic good
thing Reagan ran against George Herbert
Walker Bush said he was global as CFR
world government then they told him at
the convention okay you won we're gonna
not let you have the nomination if you
don't have put a Herbert Walker Bush
yeah then a year and they shoot him they
just released that guy
and so all this stuff went along [ __ ] I
didn't so Reagan didn't get his agenda
through and they tagged on iran-contra
all other stuff Reagan actually wanted
to get rid of the IRS and a bunch of
good stuff so yeah I know he's an anti
con so he was running against George
Bush he beat him and then when he got
the presidential nomination for the
Republican Party
they made him they forced him to take
the true story for still I think I think
just way that Ronald Reagan and I wanted
to believe in Obama but he's a total
Lovelace you know will this new tax
thing is crazy what do you think of that
it's pretty radical Joe got mad at us
trading punches Trump on Trump give me
three on people there's people out there
that think Trump is racist and they
think he's a sexist and a whoremonger
okay well good for him a lot of people
do okay so you think he's good guy I
know Trump's a good guy what he's done
is he's delivered like no president ever
all right everybody
everybody wants to find some reason to
hate him and some reason to figure out a
way to get him out of office but
shouldn't we at this point I mean he he
won their game right there's a
popularity contest he won the popularity
contest and that's really what being
president is yeah figure out a way to
get the most amount of people to say I
like you better
I mean it's really what it is and he's
the first truly popular person who's
really good at manipulating the media to
win the popularity contest everybody
before him had just been a politician
he's the first guy that's actually
famous that then became it's never yeah
but the point being that he's he wasn't
that famous Trump I don't think he was
famous like you know he's a movie star
Reagan are you that's true but I don't
think he was a big movie star I think he
was like Christian Slater no offense
Christian Slater I loved you in blade
hey who's a date Joe he was in Blade
right
Slayton blade Joe no Stephen Dorff was
what was controller and so it's Ronald
Reagan goddammit did he get his I'm
ready to end this right now but I'm
telling you once in a lifetime interview
we haven't guys are real questions we
represent no we're not three of its five
half hours yeah when did we go alive
what thirty went live a 130 we're
sitting the chair before one he's on
Austin time I know look at the clock
right next to you see it's five o'clock
yeah really told you the real truth okay
of what I've researched you shouldn't
believe MSM they're total corporate
[ __ ] you think is gonna happen how do
you think this is gonna play out now
that you think this sort of silent
bloodless coup has taken place and this
guy has gotten through this net that had
been set there to make sure that no one
other than the people that were already
inside the system could ever run it so
he got through he's said he's running it
now we're compatible once in a lifetime
situation Trump isn't perfect he really
wants to empower humanity all of us have
to work hard be involved hear our views
put on our ideas and just move forward
but they are planning to try to
assassinate Trump you think so oh god
they're demonizing him say I'm killing
him all you mean assassinating for real
or do you mean assassinate him like
publicus like politically as hell they
want to politically destroy his name and
they want to politically also try to
kill him all I know is America had half
the wealth in the world 20 years ago and
5% of the world population we've lost
half that wealth and it's that as we get
more powerful they get more powerful and
the elite have been trying to
domesticate America not that we're
perfect but we've got ideas of industry
and ideas and then doing things that
change everything and so the real leave
this planet want to kill competition
they want to consolidate control they
want to end the Internet of governments
that's America
they were about if Hillary would have
won they would have censored the inner
oh yeah together they were about to do
it okay Tom the headline is Obama
establishes Ministry of Truth three
weeks before Trump takes office one week
after Trump selected so Ministry of
Truth being something that stops fake
news right so the problem becomes how do
we decide what's fake go back please go
back please
Obama quietly signs the countering
disinformation and propaganda Act into
law Wow
late on Friday with the US population
embracing the upcoming holidays and
oblivious of most news emerging from the
administration Obama quietly signed into
law the 2017 National Defense
Authorization Act which authorizes 611
billion dollars for the military in 2017
in a statement Obama said blah blah blah
blah blah where's it say over the
governors Board of Governors the FC
federalized the media meaning
federalized television shows every all
transitions nation all galaxies your
website my website
everybody's website what do you guys
what are you doing it it says Obama
last-minute bills like all that [ __ ] he
signed read down a little lower it says
in the bill we're going to federalize
commute and put about just gonna find it
we're gonna federalize communications
and put the CIA over the board of
governors of the Federal Communications
that sounds so crazy dude you would have
been subject to that [ __ ] Hillary would
have won this close see I wonder if
people would have ever went for that
that seems let me show what Trump does
he is like up till 2:00 in the morning
everybody knows tweeting please go and
watch those video clips he gets on the
internet no he's a ghost yeah I'm not
saying Trump's perfect I'm gonna keep
Trump honest there's anything I'm gonna
come out against him the point is is
that he's a different kind of thing if
you can open 9/11
is he gonna do anything about this
already explode
the fact that elements of the government
work with Saudi Arabia to launch the
open that imagine that the alien was he
know about aliens aliens okay go ahead
so it's a green ring ring ring ring hi
Alex Oh mr. president what's going on
well women the agenda forward to cut
taxes what do you think well I don't
know about those secret space spaces
well it's you've got to come to Trump
Tower for those meetings whoo I'll come
to Trump Tower I want to open aliens hey
ask Trump if he was half on fly to New
York to be with you want to go Trump I
want to see the bodies iliyan bodies we
go to oh wow Trump on this job hangar 18
Alex imagine Trump on this show that
would be huge for him probably I do
John okay - cool we're gonna eat after
this well I we have to get the [ __ ]
outta here for sure let's talk about
whether or not we're gonna eat or
anything else but it's already five
o'clock so we're at three and a half
hours in is there anything more you have
to say before we get out of here
let me get another question is it no no
Eddie I want to ask Alex no I mean
literally I really sink the trays to try
to tell the truth and force.com has our
articles our research our videos our
podcasts what we do and I'm not left or
right
I'm not liberal or conservative I'm
really trying to find out what's going
on in the world and so after all these
years Joe this has been a I love I'm
finally finalized really good questions
you kind of knew all this I was gonna
bring up what you scary
you just keep crate you just get crazy
and you want to keep going and keep
going to keep going keep going
but I think sometimes you gotta go okay
hold that thought expand explain because
times things but hold on a second Eddie
things that are in your head
self-explanatory you already know about
it
there's a giant percentage of the people
that are listening to this I have no
idea what you're talking about
I want to say this for the Joe Rogan
listeners have an open mind you've heard
him for three and a half hours download
that app that Infowars app started
listening to him Eddie why don't you do
your showing in force that's the move to
Eddie Bravo Radio comes back on Infowars
how we do that okay boba listen all I
want people I give him a chance he
doesn't know [ __ ] about space but when
it comes to politics he's countering
foreign propaganda and disinformation
Act of 2016 the bill expresses the sense
of this bill expresses the sense of
Congress that what a weird expression
okay what are we looking at this is that
bill that anti-propaganda bill foreign
governments including the government of
the Russian Federation in China used
disinformation other propaganda tools to
undermine the national security
objectives of the United States and key
allies and partners US government should
develop a comprehensive strategy to
counter foreign disinformation and
propaganda and assert leadership in
developing a fact-based strategic
narrative and an important element of
this strategy should be to help promote
an independent press in countries that
are vulnerable to foreign disinformation
translate then MSM is on the rugs
they're panicking they want to shut down
their competition what American watching
this or listening doesn't think they
should decide what they should listen to
or not do you think that would be ever
accepted that they would allow people
someone that works in the government to
censor websites and podcasts I know it's
already happened
Oh crazy
look at that Sam bill one of the things
about podcast is that they're basically
just a pure conversation it's just
people sitting down talking and if you
if you stop your conversations I mean
that is like one of the most heinous fun
that's just too late you can't say you
can't office and they really did try to
implement some sort of I almost wish
Hillary would have one because that
could have been outside the power and I
keep Trump honest I mean I attacked
Trump and did something wrong it's hard
to find but he makes some mistakes like
torture iPhone codes or whatever but so
torture you think is just it doesn't
work it's not doesn't work it makes us
look terrible to foreign country lowers
us to their level yeah exactly
but Trump came out of it gets tortured
two days ago and said okay he changed
his mind he's good on stuff like that
well that's very nice waking up and when
you wake up you change your mind I was
also independently wealthy that's one of
them that's probably a factor in this
it's got me he's not part of the Obama
Hillary nestled that's what I'm saying
is that there's no calculation I just
treat you like I want to be treated big
stuff is happening it's a very exciting
let me ask you this before we before we
wrap this up
you know if Trump is this new stage of
politics or a new type of politician
what kind of person do you think would
be like literally the perfect person to
run this country and what would the
perfect person do Ron Paul yeah Ron
Paul's great but I think it's somebody
who's worked hard in private business
who really has a success who loves
America who has been through the
gauntlet of demonization attacks and
dealt with it yeah I think it's Donald
Trump I mean look at what he's been
through man who's been through this it
could've been a winner over and I'm not
in some cult Donald Trump right I think
I want to hate him I want to not believe
he's so good but man when he calls up
and you like read your mind and knows
what you were just thinking about you're
like man this guy is like god of the
devil this tax thing is very fascinating
it's gonna be very interesting so
seemed into me okay the mainstream it to
me every time I turn on my iPhone you
know what I didn't ask for [ __ ] Fox
News they force-feed me every morning
see you Joe robot experience yeah
Ram fo wars that's why you gotta search
because Joe's real I'm real you're real
whether we're perfect or not no matter
we want to be real everyone should human
human intelligence support this podcast
and Infowars and the Joe Rogan
experience and make this dominant which
it already is just to say listen [ __ ]
you may force-feed Eddie Bravo about you
CNN Fox News [ __ ] every morning but
you're [ __ ] getting the Joe Rogan
experience up your [ __ ] ass holy [ __ ]
every time I turn on my phone again
what is CNN trying to [ __ ] force-feed
ya those windows the iPhone force-feed
you the possessed nice guy seems like a
nice he worked there like in college
right now beyond uh beyond that he
admitted it he's part of the like web
CIA web session mock real wait a minute
CIA as a whip division yeah if you're
the Astor family like he is yeah or the
Vanderbilt or Charlotte Vanderbilt John
Jacob mr. Meyer Smith his name is my
name too
alright folks that's a wrap
no it's not no you make fun of me at the
very end we're talking about
transcendental transcending information
here Joe I think sometimes we're talking
about info wars.com
and Joe Rogan experience and Annie Bravo
conspiracy theory cuz your network if
not he believes the CIA
how does this go as well as you thought
beyond better better this was fun
it's awesome I enjoyed it what'd you
think it will be what what did you think
your 9/11 I'll show a bit oh I thought
it'd be exactly like this is as good as
I could have hoped we had a good time we
had a lot of laughs we talked about some
real [ __ ] we brought up some news
articles that confirm a lot of crazy
things that you're saying that make
people like all those new arrests their
new rest about pedophiles and sex slaves
like holy [ __ ] if that's real
what story was what a new source was
that story and how many different is it
like all over the place I mean there and
a bunch of different news sources
they're going on that one about the sex
slaves and being released in association
children yeah I'm sitting here thinking
Trump is a major force global force
right now Trump and he talks to Alex
Jones Alex Jones talks to Joe Rogan and
I'm here because of Joe Rogan I'm gonna
holy goddamn [ __ ] we got some kind of
lightning bolt going through the world
right now sure but it's not like Joe's
like it's like all this together
I'm all there it had to be like this for
it to be like this every every day
before today well however it went down
had to be like this for us for this to
happen
I wanted to be better than eight years
before I come back and you know next
time you're Austin you gotta come in
studio yeah that story that Florida and
74 stories of Russell was lying many
many many major news sites it's crazy
it's real this is a galactic thing going
down right now man well some interesting
things are happening to people and it's
happening at an accelerated rate and
we're all part of it everybody listening
to this everybody talking to their
friends every to everybody reading the
internet everybody watching
documentaries everybody reading books
everybody understanding that we know
more about how things work today than we
ever have before and it's weirder than
we ever thought and this discovery
incredible the crazy thing is is when
people aren't you know you're just not
asleep and then awake you're asleep and
then you're partially awake you know
about oh you discover you you saw sight
guys for the first time oh you're
partially away you don't know about all
this other stuff so when you hear about
all the other stuff you still got that
mentality we're like that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] people are partially
awake
not not everyone is [ __ ] though yeah
that's the problem there's a lot of
wacky dinosaurs aren't real believe is a
shark they believe it's a Greenland
shark English Archer they think it's a
shark that's like a millions millions of
years old and got into that water back
when it was connected to the ocean
because it's an ancient creature and
they used to think they're extinct but
now they don't need more they found some
so they think the Loch Ness monster that
makes sense that's what it comes down
are we talking I know but he's talking
about you talk when you're talking about
a Greenland shark my left is my
strongest everybody thanks for listening
in thanks for tuning in to episode nine
one more time Eddie Bravo Alex Jones and
Joe Rogan signing off all right Joey I'd
do it again soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]